Exzellent, chat ich bin vor euch da Wer hätte das gedacht?
Lull, noch niemand am Start, doch tatsächlich jetzt der Phipps 2 ist da
Exquisite, aber noch eine Runde Streamsore Gucken wir mal ob da das Scheiß rauskommt
oder ob ich wieder Rage quitten muss wie das letzte Mal
Ist das ein Phanto Emote oder wer ist das?
Nee keine Ahnung, sagt mir nichts
So ich komm mal, da ist die Musik nicht zu laut gemacht, da ein Ticken vielleicht
Exquisite Lautstärke
Borkers Alter, Borkers, YouTube Borkers
Wo bist du hier denn noch nirgendwo?
Im Chat bist du im Chat
Der Chat postet wieder anstößige Emotes, ich sehs schon
Toss
Du verwendest Shellichtsaus oder brennt dein Haus hin und wieder ab, ja mein Haus brennt
hin und wieder ab
Nee nee nee da macht Teams, die Teams macht nur die Mikro vor Lautstärke
Das ist wie so ein Minecraft Haus mit dem einen Server Mod
Ich hatte ja auch mal einen Minecraft Server, da gab es so einen Mod, da konntest du was
kaputt machen und er hat das automatisch wieder zusammengesetzt, das war eigentlich richtig
nice
Was ist denn LPR 0, ist das Printer Port?
Ist das Parallel Port oder?
Ach noch älter, noch älter als Parallel Port
Also ich hab ja Teams gar nicht in Cellied, ich hab ja Teams immer im Browser und trotzdem
machts das, jetzt hat es Special Rechte von Microsoft gekriegt wahrscheinlich
Also wir gucken uns heute folgendes an, guck mal hier was ich letztens gefunden hab
Deshalb bin ich ja nicht der einzige, der das gefunden hat und zwar es gibt jetzt die
Möglichkeit offiziell mit WSL grafische Anwendungen auszuführen
Das letzte Mal hatten wir ja das Problem, als wir WSL 2 ausprobiert haben, dass es mit
grafischen Anwendungen ein bisschen problematisch war
Ich hatte zum Beispiel Rider am Start als IDE und das war unbenutzbar
Und das sollte damit besser sein, das einzige Problem ist, was der Vorteil gegenüber nach
VM ist, naja, das darfst du mich nicht fragen, ich finde ja prinzipiell nach VM besser
Sagen wir mal so, die Integration mit Windows ist besser, du kannst beispielsweise Windows
Programme aus einer Linux Shell rausstarten und ich glaube auch ineinanderpipen, wenn
das die beiden Programme unterstützen
Zumal WSL 2 ist ja im Prinzip sogar eine VM, aber besser integriert, allerdings muss
ich ehrlich sagen, eine VM-VM mit grafischer Linux Oberfläche ist natürlich immer noch
besser, wenn du wirklich alles damit machen willst, gerade was grafische Programme angeht
von IDE bis Browser bis Wireshark bis sonst was
Also ich schwöre ja immer noch auf Windows als Haus und Linux in der VM, aber gerade
in der Arbeitswelt ist das so, dass viele Unternehmen sich denken, warum auch immer,
ich weiß nicht warum die sich das denken, aber sie denken sichs, Windows Only Policy
auch für ihre Linux IT Mitarbeiter einzuführen oder eingeführt haben oder schon lange haben
und dann kommst du ja an sowas nicht vorbei, direkt kündigen, ja das ist auch die zweite
Variante
So, das einzige Problem dabei ist, dass man Windows, Moment, Insider braucht, man braucht
Windows Insider Build, das heißt ich kann das hier nicht machen, ich muss mir eine Windows
VM installieren, das ist aber kein Problem, das dauert 5 Minuten oder so
Was ist der Vorteil von Linux, willst du jetzt den Vorteil von Linux allgemein wissen, in
welchem Bereich oder willst du wissen, was der Vorteil von der Linux VM ist gegenüber
WSL?
Wir probieren heute grafische Programme unter WSL aus mit diesem Ding, was Microsoft vor
einer Woche released hat
Du hast noch gar nichts verpasst, ich bin seit 5 Minuten on
Ich lade schon mal Windows ISO runter, ich glaube ich habe keine Windows ISO mehr
Es gibt allerdings ein Problem, ich habe kein Windows ISO mehr, es gibt ein Problem, mein
Festplatten platzt, wird langsam ein bisschen wenig
Aber das ist kein Ding, weil für ein ISO reichts
Windows 10 ISO, BAM
Und ich zeig den Trick immer, ich weiß, dass ich auch immer ankündige, dass ich den Trick
zeige
Aber jedes Mal sind die Leute begeistert im Chat, deswegen werde ich euch den Trick jetzt
nochmal zeigen
Also, postchamp mal für den Trick des Jahrtausends
Wenn man sich den Windows 10 ISO runterladen will, dann geht das nicht, man muss das immer
mit diesem Media Creation Tool machen
Ihr könnt aber hier einfach auf die, auf Inspect gehen und die Handyansicht anschalten
Dann Refresht ihr die Seite
Und schon könnt ihr Windows 10 runterladen, direkt als ISO
Ist das nicht poggers
Ja, das geht mit dem User Agent Switcher auch, ich weiß, dass das geht, das ist hier immer
das gleiche
Ich zeig das, der Chat erzählt mir, ja Max, das geht noch auf 50 Billionen andere Varianten
Ja
Das ist immer Cake Weight, das ist immer das gleiche
So, das laden wir auf, fuck mir fällt, ich vergesse immer, wie groß dieses Windows 10
ISO mittlerweile ist
Also, anstatt Warzone könnte man auch 20 mal Windows 10 runterladen
Warum macht es Microsoft eigentlich einem so schwer
Das ist eine gute Frage, die ich mir schon seit Jahren stelle und keine Antwort drauf
habe
Ich frag mich in vielen Bereichen, warum macht es einem Windows so schwer
Meine Lieblingssache ist ja, warum gibt es das hier
Also was ist die Daseinsberechtigung davon
Ich habe es besonderlich verstanden, was die Daseinsberechtigung davon ist, aber Microsoft
ist der Meinung, das muss so sein
Achso, Vorteile von Linux gegenüber Windows bei Arbeitsproduktivität gedöhnt sie nicht
von Gaming
Es kommt ganz entscheidend drauf an, was du als Arbeit machst
So, wenn du zum Beispiel Video, Grafik, Bearbeitung machst oder Audio oder sonst wie
Ich will nicht sagen, dass das unter Linux gar nicht geht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall
unter Windows oder teilweise auch Mac deutlich angenehmer
Wenn du allerdings Netzwerkgeschichten machst, Server administrierst, Sachen programmierst
auch nicht bei allem
Da ist es einfach angenehmer, finde ich unter Linux
Das ist der letzte, wer hat meinen Husten analysiert, habe ich Corona oder nicht
Neuestes Video ist exzellent, Dankeschön Chat exquisite
Moin Max, ich habe den Job bei Ecom 21 bekommen
Ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern was da gewesen ist
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob du das warst, es hat letztens jemand im Chat gepostet, er
weiß nicht, ob er sich als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration oder Anwendungsentwicklung
gewärmen soll
Ansonsten erzähl nochmal, ich kann mir das jetzt nicht alles wochenlang immer merken
Es ist mittlerweile einfach zu viel Chatgechette, dass ich mir das merken kann
Außerdem wird mein Hirn ja auch immer mehr Boomer hirn, das ist kein Wunder
Testen wir WSLG auf eine Hetzner-Form, ich glaube gerade grafische Ausgaben dann noch
übers Netzwerk ist low brain
Wisst ihr, ich habe mir ein YouTube Premium gekauft in Indien für 399 Rupien und da habe
ich
Das steht hier gar nicht
Und das habe ich über eine Digital Ocean Vm gemacht, weil die ein Rechenzentrum in
Indien haben
Das kostet dann plus 4,40 Euro für 3 Monate
Und das habe ich über eine Vm gemacht in Indien in Bangalore
Weiß nicht, ob man das so ausspricht, war das im Rechenzentrum
Und dort habe ich das über einen Browser in X-Forwarding gemacht
Und ich sage euch Leute, das war fucking langsam
Ja, hatten wir das letzte Mal schon
Das wird es sein, ja
Na dann, nee, kenne ich nicht
Kenne ich nicht Nein du brauchst keinen indischen Google
Account.
Der Trick ist, du musst dir ein indisches Bezahlprofil anlegen.
Bezahlprofil oder wie hieß das?
Ne Zahlungsprofil hieß das glaube ich oder?
Genau, du musst in dein Google Account gehen und das hier machen.
Du gehst in eine Einschätzung Zahlungsprofil und dann legst du ein neues Zahlungsprofil
für Indian an und addest dort deine Kreditkarte.
Es ist ja nach wie vor Google, also es macht keinen Unterschied ob es Google Indian ist
oder sonst wie.
Danach kannst du die Kreditkarte übrigens auch wieder löschen, juck kein.
Und dann kaufst du dir YouTube Premium für drei Monate.
Du musst das alle drei Monate erneuern, aber so ein großer Akt ist das jetzt nicht.
Aber es dauert ein Viertelstunde.
Das kommt jetzt, da habe ich Ragequitted, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Kann man auch machen.
Es gibt viele Wege zum indischen YouTube Premium Account.
Ich finde es aber immer genial, wie der Chat immer besser weiß was ich hätte machen sollen
als ich selbst.
Der Chat weiß das ja prinzipiell, auf der anderen Seite so weit hin ist es natürlich
nicht, der Chat hat mittlerweile so oft reingestoppt und so high IQ, der weiß es wahrscheinlich
wirklich besser.
Was ist eigentlich besser, Chromium oder Chromium, das macht im Endeffekt keinen Unterschied.
In Chromium hast du ein paar Chrom Sachen nicht drinnen, je nach Bild und manchmal
hast du mehr Probleme mit 2D, 3D Beschleunigung und sowas, aber im Prinzip macht es keinen
Unterschied.
Chromium ist ein unabhängig von Google gebauter Chrome, also wenn du jetzt hingehst und lädst
dir den Source Code von Chrome runter und baust den und kompilierst den so, dass die
Chromium Leute auch.
Kann man auch machen, aber du brauchst immer noch eine VM in Indien, warum machst du eine,
kannst du machen?
Kannst du mich jetzt gut wie alles fragen, ob ich es dann beantworte, sei mal dahingestellt,
das sagt es ja nicht.
Ja vor zig Jahren, das sagt, ganz ehrlich, mach eine Linux VM und gut ist.
So, also, wenn du eine VM installierst, gehts schnell.
Was ist die beste Distro für WSL, Windows, was denn sonst, ok, ich nehme immer Ubuntu,
Ubuntu, Moment, Moment, wo hab ich, ok, neue VM, zack, ich hab immer noch 15.5 installiert,
so, next, Workstation, ja ja, blablabla, later, wir wollen Windows installieren, Windows
10, X64, nein, aber nicht da, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist verkehrt, wir wollen
es auf E-Doppelpunkt, VMs, jetzt machen wir neun, oh guck mal, das heißt, delete me, hätte
ich vielleicht delete me auch deleteen sollen, wobei ich glaube, delete me ist cutebuntu,
kann das sein, ich sollte mal meine VMs aufräumen, glaube ich, ich blicke da nicht mal durch,
ok, evi boot, wir machen drei CPUkerne, ach komm, scheiß, vier CPUkerne, ach komm, drei,
drei, wir wollen uns aber nicht übertragen, 8G RAM, bin ich froh, dass ich mir damals noch
zwei 16G Riegel, oder zwei, nee, 16G Riegel, ob noch gekauft hab, dass ich jetzt 32G hab,
das lohnt sich für VMs und so Testdinger immer richtig, so nut, wait a minute, warum
ist die Musik jetzt so laut, Mario Kart kann sich mal wieder nicht entscheiden, Mario Kart
erst mal wieder, Pepega Kart, so, next, next, next, 16G, jawoll, next, next, so Drucker
raus, next, finish, so und jetzt das ISO Mountain und dann, wisst ihr eigentlich wie froh ich
bin, dass Cortana einen nicht mehr vollschwätzt bei der Windows Installation, oder ist das
nur in Professional so, labert die eine in der Homeversion noch zu, war da nicht irgendwas,
so, Display, Accelerate 3D Graphics, Nested Virtualization, machen wir natürlich an, sonst
funktioniert der ganze Kram nicht, ja wir müssen es nested virtualisieren, uns bleibt
nix anderes da übrig, wir müssen Windows Installer installieren und das kann ich hier
nicht machen, was in Home labert ein Cortana voll, hallo ich bin Cortana, ja, hat die eigentlich
die Stimme aus Halo, von der Halo Cortana, ich hab mir das nie so wirklich im Vergleich
angehört, wusste ihr, dass die alte Sprecherin von Cortana die gleiche ist, die Peach glaube
ich in Mario 64 gesprochen hat, so, Time Currency, nee nee Keyboard German, eher German, warum
stellt er das, Uganda, alter, war da grad, so, Language to Install, ja wunderbar, Ext,
ich installier grad Windows auf Windows, ja das macht Sinn, in dem Fall macht das sogar
viel Sinn, so, Professional, Ext, kann ich gleich dem Chat noch ne Runde widmen, während
er das installiert, ja ja Windows komm, mach, exellent, ISO passt, wisst ihr was wir dann
theoretisch mal machen könnten, was ich das letzte Mal nicht ausprobiert habe mit WSL,
geht KVM in WSL, da könnten wir quasi Windows, VMWare, WSL, KVM, Windows, WSL, KVM, Windows,
WSL, KVM machen, da hätten wir wenn das, wenn KVM in WSL geht, dann hätten wir quasi
ein unendlicher Virtualisierungs Cycle geschaffen, ich weiß halt nicht wie schnell das läuft,
ne, also ja das ganze in Docker, was sonst, wobei das keinen Sinn ergibt, aber was auch
immer, KVM geht nicht, wir suchen doch einfach mal, WSL2, KVM, anscheinend doch, Accelerated
und KVM Guests und WSL2, was bezieht sich hier Accelerated, exellent Accelerated, was
genau soll das bringen, vor allem was ist dann davon Accelerated, ok das sieht ein wenig
komplizierter aus, das sieht ein wenig komplizierter aus mit eigenem Kernel Kompilieren und Geschirrts,
um KVM zu verwenden, in WSL, scheint ein bisschen aufwendiger zu sein, for now native GUI super
ein, GPU Acceleration ist coming, ahja gut die meinen, Virtualisierungs Extensions in
der CPU, ne ne das glaube ich zu übertrieben jetzt, hatte, was ich hatte ein Bug in System
CTL, also System D geht doch unter WSL gar nicht richtig, ne, das hatten wir doch gerade
schon, hast nicht wirklich einen Unterschied, Chromium ist quasi ein Chrome den andere Leute
kompiliert haben als Kugel, Captain Seeker 12 Monate, erster Hypersubscriber hier, Twitchcom
Amsterdam exquisite, und er war hier schon ganz am Anfang dabei, so wie sieht die Installation
aus, oh wir sind fast durch, Poggers, wenn ich was über sehe schreibts einfach nochmal
in Chat, ich sehe nicht alles wenn so viel los ist im Chat, so just a moment, ah das ist
der typische Windows Gebate, das schreibt Windows ja schon seit Jahrzehnten und man
glaubts immer wieder, yes, nein, warum, kann mir jemand die Logik dahinter erklären, warum
muss ich das Keyboard auswählen, warum muss ich das Keyboard nochmal auswählen, vor allem
warum muss ich das jetzt in so ne beschissenen Menü auswählen wo ich noch nicht mal G drücken
kann um auf German zu switchen, Phoenix Dankeschön für, Phoenix Dankeschön für den Sub, 18
Monate das ist ja auch wieder Messer Hypersubscriber hier, so, yes, skip, oh jetzt muss ich gleich
30 Billionen mal, ich will keine Sachen an Microsoft schicken ankreuzen, Prick Dankeschön
für die 3 Monate Subscription, nein Bitworn hab ich doch, doch stimmt gar nicht, wir haben
sogar Bitworn im Stream schon mal installiert, oder, wir müssen gar nicht mehr sicher haben
wir das mal gemacht, ich glaube schon das ist aber ne Weile her, war ganz ok, ich persönlich
bin aber immer noch Keypass Fan, das liegt zum größten Teil daran, weil ich halt nicht
im Browser, weil ich das nicht auf zig Geräten verwenden muss und weil ich mein ganzes Zeug
schon in den Keypass drin hab, ich weiß man kann Keypass irgendwie exportieren zu Bitworn
aber das hab ich noch nicht gemacht, man kann nicht mal No Dead Keys wählen, ich glaube
das ist Default unter Windows, der Installer ist extrem schlecht, unglaublich ja, ja mittlerweile
glaube ichs, ich hab's am Anfang aber auch nicht geglaubt, ok, oh jetzt kommt, jetzt
kommt auch wieder so ein Windows Nerv Ding ne, jetzt wollen sie dir ein Microsoft Account
aufschwätzen, man muss jetzt sagen, ja Personal Use, nein ich will kein E-Mail, Phone oder
Skype, ich will ein Offline Account und jetzt fragen sie noch mal, seid ihr euch sicher,
ihr wollt ein Offline Account, ja ich will Limited Experience, ah ja ok und jetzt darf
ich, oh nein vielleicht doch ein Online Account, dazu kann ich nur sagen Microsoft, 1 2 3
4 5 6, 1 2 3 4 5 6, Security Question 1, achso ja, 2, 3, excellent, highly secure, ok
don't use, accept, no, accept, no, accept, jetzt kommen wir, achso by the way was ich
auch geil finde, es gibt nur additional und send, es gibt nicht off, no, no, no, chat
ihr kennt mein Passwort, da hab ich ja gar nicht dran gedacht jetzt, chat ist bestimmt
schon eingeloggt, echt Enterprise hat das, ja wahrscheinlich sind es denen auf den Dach
gestiegen, nein nein nein kein Cortana please, hi, im Prinzip einfach auch wieder Zeitschinderei,
jetzt muss ich mir erstmal ein Chrome installieren und erst nochmal schauen, dass ich die Anleitung
von Microsoft aufmache wie man WSL 2 installiert, das sind ja ein paar Schritte erforderlich
für, wie war nochmal das Passwort, admin, admin, nee ich benutze Edge nicht auch wenn
es Chromium Edge ist, Horstchamp, Horstchamp, was ist eigentlich das Ziel WSL 2 zu installieren
und grafische GUI Programme auszuprobieren mit WSL G was seit einer Woche erschienen
ist, steht ja im Titel, WSL G ausprobieren ist das Ziel, EE geht auch immer noch, wir
haben ein Zeiterfassungssystem auf der Arbeit, das steht immer noch beim Einloggen drin,
optimiert für Microsoft Internet Explorer, fehlt bloß noch das drin, steht für Microsoft
Internet Explorer 800 x 600, nein maybe later, so voran wir Tools installieren, install,
go, go, go, der Hype Train Leute noch eine Minute, da gibt es Poggers Emotes für alle,
easy Hype Train geschafft, erste Runde Emotes ist durch, Mr. Knarff, danke schön für
das, massive Subscriptions, hier wieder high IQ, IQ++, so, ah ja man muss ja neu starten,
ein paar Windows habe ich vergessen, das ist immer noch ein paar Windows so drin, dass
ich das einfach random neu starten möchte, obwohl es auch ohne geht, was, an meiner Uni
arbeite ich immer mit so einem Humanoid Roboter, extrem veraltet, das Linus wird passen, so
super Humanoid, Humanoiden Roboter kann er ja nicht sein, das Passwort ist Root Sixhead,
das ist ein gutes Passwort, das ist auch auf jeden Fall standhaft gegen jegliche Attacke,
ich meine zeig mir mal ein Wörterbuch in dem Sixhead drin steht, so, da sind wir wieder,
hier lernt man wieder was, ok zack installiert wunderbar, jetzt brauchen wir ganz schnell
noch ein Chrome und dann müssen wir Windows Insider, Microsoft ist schon, Microsoft ist
schon dezent nervig mit ihrem Crap oder, wow, wow, was war das, also Chrome Download, der
Chat war das, schon wieder, nein nein nein, nicht Chrome, nicht Chrome, please, please,
please, Chrome auf Englisch, nein ich will auch Chrome nicht besser machen, ich will
eigentlich nix besser machen, ich will den Crap nur verwenden, wo mich drüber aufregen
wenn es schlecht ist, hast du direkt ein Insider ISO Insider, das gibt's, Moment, es gibt
ISO Insider, es gibt ISO, es gibt Insider ISOs, ernsthaft, keck wait, gibt's echt Insider
ISOs, da hättest du es mal machen sollen, wo gibt's denn die, Windows Insider ISO, aha,
oh fuck, da muss man sich ja mit dem Microsoft Account einloggen, ich hab doch kein Microsoft
Account hier, da hab ich ja überhaupt nicht dran gedacht, was soll denn da scheiß, ok
da müssen wir jetzt irgendwie gucken, wie man damit, was, was ist das, die VM ist gecrashed,
keck wait, das hatte ich ja noch nie, ich mach mir einfach einen neuen Microsoft Account,
naja ich mach irgendeinen 10 minute Mail oder so, ok, der Achille macht Microsoft, das ist
eine gute Idee, so also wie funktioniert das jetzt überhaupt mit Insider Builds, hallo,
wie, wie, wie würde man jetzt Insider machen, Insider, ah hier, ne, was ist das denn, Insider,
ah hier, lulw, ok ich bin da, ich bin da zu pepega für, ja get started, ok, ok, ok,
ok, also wir brauchen einen Microsoft Account, habe ich das richtig verstanden, also dann
machen wir uns mal einen fake Microsoft Account, auf geht's würde ich sagen, also 10 minute
Mail, naja wir stimmen zu, wir stimmen zu, 10 minute Mail, also welche ist denn davon
nochmal die richtige, die da, ne, die da, das ist glaube ich die gute, in die Zwischenablage,
exzellent, Microsoft Account, kann man hier einen neuen Account erstellen, oh, was, was,
was zum, von KS, erstellen einen Microsoft Account, zack, ich hoffe die wollen nicht,
dass ich mich telefon verifizieren muss, dann habe ich echt ein Problem, Moment, Moment,
ich muss mal kurz mal mir ein Passwort überlegen, Deutschland, 1.
1980, oh ne, weiter, ok, hoffentlich kommt jetzt kein Porn Werbung oder so, warum will
Google Access, ok, Wonka, ist das bei Microsoft geblockt, das ist bestimmt bei Microsoft
geblockt, ne, you block Origin, 5 fat Microsoft, ne, wait a minute, ah, man sieht das Fenster
nicht, aha, bestätigen Sie die E-Mail Adresse, 3015, weiter, bitte lösen Sie das
Puzzle, damit wir wissen, dass Sie kein Roboter sind, welches Puzzle, what the, ah jetzt,
denken Sie auf die File, so fertig, huge, massive Puzzle, ok, da haben wir unseren Microsoft
Account, nice, wie war die E-Mail Adresse nochmal, sign in, ne, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
habe ich was falsches angeklickt, hä, ah, keck wait, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ich muss mal kurz Passwort und E-Mail in Textdokument offensplessen Bildschirm kopieren,
Ah, yes exquisite
Jaja
Okay, warum auch immer man da sich so ein fake account join jaja was you need an account register and to get inside a briffy
Bills register register
Sign up jaja ja alles klar mache ich mache ich mal cross off gar kein ding. You're good to go
exquisite ok wie lange dauert das jetzt
This won't take long die jebaiten uns bestimmt
Wir sehen uns 22 m in der
Zwischenzeit hast zwei kinder gezeugt bis das fertig ist wahrscheinlich
Punchy live dankeschön für prime gaming subscription
Das won't take long habe ich euch schon mal gesagt dass es nicht lang dauert
Pausierungs champ
Ja ich finde diese banner auch hässlich ist nicht so dass die windows banner früher schöner waren aber die sind auch besonders hässlich
Die mann sleep random wahrscheinlich dass es nicht zu klein nicht immer zu klein nicht immer gleich ist ja
Am besten sind die cup just die überhaupt keine brauchen also überhaupt keine interaktion mehr
Ich brauche sage ich dir falls es jetzt nicht geht ich brauche mindestens insider breath
2 1 3 6 2
Ich habe ihn gestern auf dem twitter mal angeschrieben wie es aussieht oder vorgestern
Irgendwann wie es aussieht immer noch grafisch windows please aber wenn man auch grafisch stellt es macht wenn das nächste
Battlefield was taugt pass mal auf pass mal
How long does insider review take
Was ist das hier schon wieder
Bei euch hat sofort geklappt ja
Scheint gut zu funktionieren wenn das insider
Review
Die reddit antwort war auch total sinnlos was willst du da sehen
Guck die reddit antwort ist richtig fehlen von 2016
Was kann man hier eigentlich geiles jetzt machen mit dem microsoft account ich bin da sonst nie eingelogged
Gilt er gilt er auch für xbox der gleiche account
Das bestimmt verbuckt aus irgendwelchen gründen
Moment wir jetzt können wir uns doch eine iso downloaden warte mal iso download insider
Jetzt sind wir doch eingelogged was was flight hab
Die page loaded doch wirklich sehr schnell
Das ist warum ist eigentlich das so kaputt hier 2 1 3 5 brauche ich das ist das was die auch haben wollten
2 1 3 6 2
Es gibt kein iso für die version die sprache
Die isos sind alle zu alt
Kann man vom iso dann updaten aufs neueste
Ja ja sign in sign in
Ja ja mach
Guck mal das ist ja noch älter
Das gibt es alles gar nicht was ich brauche
So das funstnet
Das one take long ganz bestimmt
Was passiert wenn ich cancel mache
Was jetzt
Wie wollen die mich verarschen jetzt geht es oder was
Windows
Windows logik das muss man nicht verstehen one take long du musst abbrechen nochmal neu und dann geht's
Das wird mich bei microsoft alles nicht wundern
Pixel 9 90 dankeschön für den sap massive big brain zwei monate subscription
Wisst ihr was ich extrem cringe fand früher und heute auch immer noch extrem cringe finde
Die leute die früher nicht microsoft geschrieben haben sondern mini war ich
Das war das ist also wenn das nicht boomer humor ist dann weiß ich auch nicht
Das ist das ist so extremer boomer humor das ist schon immer feierlich
Richtiger boomer humor
So und wie wie privacy update leute das microsoft gerade ich check für updates
So und wie wie upgrade ich jetzt auf preview bild
Wie geht das jetzt updates checken chat ihr seid die windows experten ihr müsst mir sagen wie das jetzt funktioniert
Das hat keiner gesagt wenn es keiner gesagt hat wie komme ich dann da drauf
Meinst du ich habe mir das jetzt ausgedacht
Ach hier insider revief wie lang dauert es jetzt so wie lang dauert es jetzt so ich dachte es dauert vielleicht nicht ganz so lang
Aber sieht aktuell schon ziemlich pains champing ah ne ah ne ok ok jetzt gibt er jetzt gibt er gas jetzt gibt er gas
Es dauert nicht bis morgen ich habe das schon mal gemacht so lange dauert das auch nicht
Du musst noch ein was muss ich aufbauen ein sccm das klingt nach irgendeinem vorläufer von von shit
Restart required und weshalb
Guck mal jetzt jetzt flutscht jetzt flutscht easy easy
System center configuration manager das kenne ich nicht das klingt aber wie irgendwas ganz schreckliches aus der microsoft welt was eigentlich niemand haben will
Ist es auch
Also wie neun neun schon microsoft
Was hat man lasst mal kurz überlegen was hat denn microsoft gutes die haben studio code die haben github wobei sie dafür nichts können
Visual studio selbst auch nicht so schlecht wird alle wollen mich veräppeln dort net richtig dort net
Die xbox meinetwegen auch teams geht halbwegs
Es hat microsoft sonst noch mixer
Ansonsten
Weiß nicht
Wenn es einem gefällt ja
Ja kann ich wenig zu sagen hab da nicht viel mitgemacht und alles was wir gemacht haben war eigentlich im stream
Wir haben damit ein bisschen video video gerendert weiß ich noch aber das war es
Microsoft sql server wusste dir dass der microsoft sql server jetzt auch unter windows läuft unter unter lilux meine ich läuft
Disco noch hat microsoft ja kein discord gekauft es gibt ja irgendwie das gerücht das microsoft discord kauft da gibt es noch nichts neues oder
Typescript Typescript ja Typescript ist auch nice 9 90 prozent
One note ist ganz okay das stimmt ja das neue one note kenne ich nicht es ist auch ganz okay also was was auf jeden fall was auf jeden fall nicht
Gutes ist weil es gerade einer im chat schreibt what the fuck chat ist auf jeden fall nicht microsoft atp das ist bei der weide der windows defender
Windows defender klingt aber zu langweilig das ist die Microsoft advanced threat protection
Discord hat nein gesagt das finde ich gut guck mal das das flutscht richtig seht ihr das bam ba ba bam ihr habt atp gerade ausgerollt proxy
Ob habt ihr linux oder habt ihr windows oder solaris oder hpux oder zos ne was habt ihr auf was habt ihr das ausgerollt
Kennst du dich mit der referenzspannung bei einem adc aus nur insoweit ich das mal mit mir sp 32 gemacht hab und da hab ich einfach so lange ausprobiert bis es
Hinkommt
Windows kleines only ja um dich jetzt mal zu schocken zu schocken proxy obs wir betreiben über 4000 linux systeme und big stonks leute haben sich als
Microsoft consultants eingekauft und die sind da meinung wir müssten windows atp windows defender auf allen linux servers installieren
Kein witz habe ich ja schon öfters erzählt und das beste ist wir haben das jetzt auf unserem linux fileserver drauf und microsoft der also der der windows defender
Ist ohne scheiß kein witz was ich euch jetzt erzähl der windows defender nachdem wir den gestartet haben auf unserem auf unserem linux fileserver hat gesagt 380 bedrohungen erkannt
Und wenn man sich dann den report anguckt was es für bedrohungen sind hat der windows defender gesagt sie haben offene file handles da hab ich mir gedacht was auf einem file server offene
File handles das ding musst du gleich sofort kappen und verschrotten also das ist ja das ist verseucht das kannst du nicht mehr retten
So eine scheiß software alter und dann verursacht es teilweise auch noch sinnlos cpu las achja und das beste das beste hab ich euch ja noch gar nicht erzählt
Der windows defender schickt logs an microsoft und dann hast du so ein dashboard so ein log explorer da kannst du beispielsweise sehen was leute auf dem server gemacht haben
Und letztens haben wir da reingeguckt und ein kollege hat sein password im klartext in den microsoft defender logs gefunden
Ich weiß nicht wer da wen protectet ich weiß nicht wer da wen protectet ehrlich gesagt ich hab nicht das gefühl das uns microsoft protectet mit dieser software
Es gibt eine binary exploitation bei offenen files was soll denn das bedeuten
Was was was möchtest du mir damit sagen es gibt einen exploit bei offenen files what
Warum soll es einen exploit geben wenn files offen sind sag mal mal so du hast du hast wenn du einen file öffnest und ich schließt dann hast du potenziell
Du hast keine probleme aber du hast potenziell mehr probleme weil linux soweit ich weiß file rechte nur beim öffnen checkt und nicht mehr später also sprich wenn du beispielsweise sudo was öffnest oder was startest was root hat
Und danach keine root mehr dann bleibt das file aber mit root geöffnet was was relativ sinnvoll ist weil sonst müsste das bei jedem bei jedem bit was gelesen und geschrieben wird zugriffsrechte kontrolle machen das machen sie nicht
Deswegen solltest du auch eigentlich nur files solange auflassen wie du brauchst
Aber was eine eine binary exploitation bei offenen files sein soll weiß ich nicht
Die next critical information ja offensichtlich dann erklärt mir chat high IQ chat schießt los ihr habt ja anscheinend information
Ihr hattet davor mcafee das war noch schlimmer wir hatten davor kaspersky das war auch nicht schön
Maybe den freunde pointer auf files hijacken vielleicht keine ahnung
Wie kaspersky ist nicht schön du kommst denn am start das ist natürlich auch eine gute idee ja wenn ich das nächste mal mein passport vergeben habe rufe ich einfach bei peter vom indischen microsoft support an frag ob er mein passport restoren kann
Das ding ist wirklich ein advanced keylogger aber ein advanced keylogger den man absichtlich installiert da drauf das ist der komplette witz
Das meine ich doch da siehst du da hast du logs drinnen wo du unter anderem das passport siehst von leuten wenn die ein kommando eingegeben haben oder sich irgendwo vertippt haben und so
Ja windows defender ist nicht schlecht aber halt als client windows gestellte nicht als linux server 51% leute postchamp vielleicht gehts weiter
This wont take long haben sie gesagt und wir haben es ihnen geglaubt
Da war das schlimmste produkt sind immer noch blu code proxies code blu code was ist das sagt mir nix
Zeit für fortnite ja genau ganz genau ich der große huge fortnite spieler bin ich bin wirklich kalt in meinem zweiten leben wenn ich nicht youtube mache oder arbeiten gehe bin ich fortnite pro
Hab ich nur noch keinem erzählt
Wie ist das password eigentlich gelandet ich denke mal der hat sich einfach vertippt und die shell hat gesagt falscher befehl und bam
Echt jaja klar zweifelst du etwa da dran was ich sag
Kann das kann das sein
Ein agiler fortnite pro
Ich habe die tastatur auch 90 grad angewinkelt kennen das die ganzen fortnite pros die spielen mit angewinkelte tastatur
So so spielen so spielen sie die ganzen fortnite pros
Guckt euch an
Der dcs leute machen das weil die früher so viel so so extrem high sens gespielt haben also platz gebraucht haben bei fortnite ist es ja anscheinend so dass du von den key bindings her besser klar kommst wenn du es angewinkelt hast
Hier why do fortnite players angle their keyboard ich kann es euch nicht erklären aber wenn es euch interessiert müsst ihr euch das video angucken
Best fortnite player also der calis 10
Was zum geil warum sind die ganzen 10 ok das ist fortnite das wundert mich jetzt ja ehrlich gesagt nicht natürlich sind halt 10 jährigen am start
So haben wir es jetzt 65 prozent
Handgelenke dann mit 20 ja man kann nicht alles haben kann ich krasse hacker mein fortnite pro sein und und mit 20 noch eine funktionierende hand entscheidet sich für eins
Ist das nicht ab 18 nee oder ab wann ist fortnite ab 12 ab 16 ich habe keine ahnung als würde das überhaupt irgendjemand interessieren
Ab 12 also auf jeden fall nicht ab 18
Jetzt wurde das interessiert was ist eigentlich aus realm royal geworden das fand ich ja zwischenzeitlich ganz unterhaltsam
Nichts wahrscheinlich oder
Viel spieler hat es noch zeit mal her
Na ok ich meine es ist jetzt nicht komplett im arsch aber
Ich meine es ist schon ziemlich schlecht wenn man sich überlegt wie gut das gestartet ist
Na ja man kann es doch spielen das war es dann aber die jugendschutzbeauftragung wollen sie ab 18 machen mit welcher begründung denn
Die jugendschutzbeauftragung die werden auch sind nur auf das game aufmerksam geworden weil es bekannt ist
Wie bist du eigentlich auf den keks gekommen ich hatte früher ganz am anfang hatte ich als avatar nen linux pinguin als keks
Gucken ob ich das finde warte mal tux gucki avatar mal gucken ob man das noch findet
Ich hatte nen linux pinguin als keks und das war mir dann zu monka tost und zu unpassend dann habe ich dann
Irgendwann gesagt ich will einen eigenen keks dann hat mir ich glaube ich glaube skillfile da hieß er damals
Hat mir der hat mir auch den alten kanalhintergrund gemacht hat an den keks geboren
Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr genau alles schon so lange her
Ja und so sieht es jetzt aus jetzt haben wir auch huge keks emote
Und ich weiß nicht ob ich schon gesehen habt wir haben ja ein paar neue ne am besten finde ich am besten finde ich ehrlich gesagt den hier
Das ist der beste wenn ihr keinen bock mehr auf stream habt guck
Wenn ihr keinen bock mehr auf den stream habt dann geht ihr ein stück guckt euch um und dann haut ihr ab
Der ist das der beste
Ich finde das geil wie das sich nochmal umdreht
Ja aber das ist das kann jeder verwenden wir haben auch ein paar subscriber
Ich wusste das wir corona keks haben sogar
Und das aller das allerbeste ist natürlich immer noch
Super mario 7 7 9 9 dankeschön für den sub
Punchy live hat abonniert dankeschön für den sub habe ich gar nicht übersehen
Wegen der frage max vorhand aber nice danke mr knarf habe ich glaube ich übersehen huge subscriptions für 34 minuten dankeschön für den sub
Je weit bist du schon gekommen ich hoffe der kram ist jetzt fertig installiert noch 20%
Ich mache gerade windows insider build installationen weil ich habe festgestellt man braucht einen windows insider build dafür
Weiß ich grad nicht
Leute abschießen ist größte boomer aussagen ja das stimmt
Das stimmt
Das ist so wie meine mutter früher immer gesagt hat
Na klimperst du wieder an deinem nintendo
Diese wortwahl ich war weder an einem nintendo noch habe ich was geklimpert
Ich habe am pc gesessen oder am computer gesagt so dinger gemacht
Klippers du wieder an deinem nintendo
Daddeln. Daddeln ist auch, ähm, Fail.
Ja, also meine nennt das Nintendo, weil die kennt irgendwie nur Nintendo. Für die ist
auch ein Xbox Nintendo.
Was willst du genau mit dem Windows Insider Bild machen? Grafische Anwendung unter WSL
ausprobieren, weil Microsoft hat vor einer Woche irgendwas released, womit das angeblich
viel besser geht. Eben bei Hetzan registriert. Exquisite. Muss ja sagen, dass Konsolen auch
jetzt... Ja. Die haben das wirklich cool gemacht. Ich wusste zwar nicht, dass es RGB Farben
hat. Ja. Hast du auch, wie viel Guthaben hast du bekommen, hast du auch 20 Euro oder 23,80
gekriegt. Manche haben nämlich gesagt, man bekommt 23,80. Wenn man dann auch den Fanatic
Headshot Controller hat, dann kann nix mehr schief gehen, weil der ist auch bei Jung und
Alt der Hit. Oder was erzählt der Typ nochmal? Der King, sagt er, der King. Sie sind dort
in jedem Spiel der King, erzählt er doch in dieser Werbung. So, 93% Postchamp, gleich
haben wir es. Seit wann bist du live? Seit 1 Stunde 3 Minuten 51 Sekunden. 23,80. Exzellent.
Ist es eigentlich den RGB entsprechend, sich einen zweiten Account zu machen? Kein Schimmer.
Was findest du besser? Vmware oder Virtualbox? Vmware. Ganze Benutz- Usability ist, finde
ich, viel angenehmer mit Vmware Workstation. 100%? Das heißt, jetzt ist er fertig? Oder
ist das Microsoft Gebaidet 100%? Erfahrung mit QEMO-Virtualisierung, ja. Achso, du meinst
wirklich QEMO in Form von zum Beispiel eine Arm auf dem x86 oder so? Oder was meinst
du? 100%? Hat Virtualbox immer noch diese USB3-Lizenz? Keine Ahnung, ich hab Virtualbox schon
seit 2 Jahren nicht mehr verwendet. Pending Restart, ok, Poggers jetzt, bam. Vielleicht
war das jetzt zu schnell oder macht noch das. Das war auch geil, ne? Die ganzen Noobs früher,
ich kann mich, oh ne, please, please. Mein Vater früher, der hat immer auf die Festplattenanzeige
geguckt vom Rechner und hat immer die Maus nicht bewegt und hat dabei gesagt, er arbeitet
noch, er arbeitet noch. Nichts machen, er arbeitet noch. Nur weil die Festplattenanzeige geplinkt
hat. Da sieht man mal, was Unwissenheit alles macht bei den Leuten, ja. Aber was auch witzig
ist, der hat ja bis heute nicht gecheckt, dass die Sache Desktop heißt, sondern sagt
immer noch Descope. Ich mach mir das jetzt auf Descope. Was nutzt du denn anstelle von
Virtualbox für die VM? VMA Workstation benutze ich. Ich benutze KeyPass, ich benutze das
hier. Alter, was ist das für ein Auf, oh ne, oder? Was macht ihr jetzt? Leute, wir waren
bei 100% Microsoft, hört auf mich zu gibbaden. Wenn ihr 100% schreibt, dann soll es auch
100% sein, nicht 3%. Ok, wir gucken jetzt einfach nicht hin, dann gehts schneller. Ich
benutze das hier, KeyPass für Passportstelle. Ist nicht das einzig Gute, gibt noch ein
paar andere sinnvolle Sachen, aber ich hab das einfach schon seit Jahren und deswegen.
Bleib ich da jetzt erstmal bei. Ok, es geht halbwegs schnell. Wie gesagt, grafische Programme
unter VSL ausprobieren. Mehr kann ich dir auch noch nicht sagen, weil ich das nicht
ausprobiert hab. Leute denken, wir müssen danach unbedingt einen Snapshot machen. Ah,
guck mal, Microsoft. Was hast du für VMA Workstation gezahlt? 16 Euro oder so was, oder 25 Euro
glaub ich. Gibt es genug Keyshops? Ah, 30% wird neu gestartet, ok. Microsoft Logik. Guck
mal jetzt, jetzt Jumps. Come on brah. Auf, gib alles Windows. Waiters kann man einmalig
kaufen und muss nicht monatlich zahlen, natürlich. Vor allem bei Workstation kannst du einmalig
kaufen. Das gilt aber nur für die aktuelle Version, deswegen hab ich auch noch 15,5.
Anstatt 16. Haben wir es jetzt? Oh, noch mal restarten. Warum wohnt? Warte, das hab ich
schon mal erzählt, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt nochmal erzähle. Ganz kurz,
ich hab mit meinem Vater nicht allzu viel Kontakt mehr und ich bin da auch ehrlich gesagt
ganz froh drüber, wir sind da nicht so, wir hatten da schon die ein oder anderen Probleme,
ja, sagen wir mal so. In der Regel hab ich Kontakt mit meinem Vater dann, wenn er Geld
von mir haben will und warum er nicht bei mir wohnt ist relativ easy, weil der mit, als
ich, als war ich denn da, keine Ahnung, drei oder so, weil der, als ich drei war mit irgendeiner
aus Polen glaube ich fremd gegangen ist und meine Mutter ihn rausgeschmissen hat. So,
deswegen wohnt er nicht mehr bei uns. Und ich hab mit ihm nichts zu tun, das einzige,
wo ich öfters mal was von ihm höre ist, wenn er Geld will. So, oh, wir haben es fast geschafft.
Übrigens, ihr könnt euch ja noch an den Stream erinnern, wo ich so ein Webinterface für
meine Überwachungskameras gebaut hab. Mein Vater ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum ich
mir die erste Überwachungskamera installiert hab an meinem Haus. Ich wollt wissen, wenn
mein Vater vor der Tür steht, dass ich dann entweder direkt sagen kann, gibt nichts oder
einfach AFK faken. Guck ich dann einfach auf mein Tablet im Flur, sag, oh, es ist mein
Vater, ich bin nicht da. Gag wait. Ist eigentlich, eigentlich, eigentlich richtig next level,
also. Afk faken, ja okay, das sagt glaub ich keiner außer der Friseur und ich, wir sagen
immer afk faken. Weil, weil der Master Krabber immer AFK gefakt hat früher. Der Karsten,
der Karsten hat immer AFK gefakt. Weil wir zu viel dummes Zeug gelabert haben, hat der
Karsten immer AFK gefakt. Und nein, nicht der Allotricks Karsten, weil das jetzt wieder
kommt da. Dem hab ich doch sonst gar nichts zu tun, ich weiß gar nicht, wie der immer
drauf kommt. Der Karsten mit K, der Master Krabber. So, login please Windows. Cringe
Fakt. Seit dem einen Video mit dem Friseur heiße ich in allen Games Hoden. Das find
ich gut. Ich heiße in Battlefield Bad Company 2 auch Hoden. Bester Name. Was hat denn PC
so für Specs, das ist in 8700K, bissl übertaktet, wobei übertaktet ist er nicht mehr, stimmt
nicht mehr, hab ich wieder weggemacht. Unsinnig Stromverbrauch. 130G RAM und 1080Ti. Und RGB
RAM. Das glaub ich die wichtigste Sache, das muss man natürlich erwähnen, da kannst du
nämlich alles nochmal 20% höher rechnen. So, haben wir es jetzt geschafft. Ok, Snapshot.
Erstmal einen Snapshot machen, Snapshot. Deswegen, by the way, Forever Workstation
ist auch top. Vergleich zu Player und sowas. Cortana ist now configured. Ich will Cortana.
Privacy Update, ja. Genau. Ah, ich muss mich, jetzt versteh ich das Microsoft. Ich muss
mich einloggen, damit die Privacy höher wird. Jetzt hab ich das endlich mal verstanden.
So, ist doch logisch. So, also wie funktioniert das jetzt? Meist sonnig, Standort liegt,
das ist neu anscheinend da unten. Guck mal, man kann jetzt auch Emojis Reactions machen.
Skandal im Impfzentrum in Finland. Kann ich das jetzt reacten? Nee, ich kann nicht reacten.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, geh weg. Nein, ich will ja nicht ins sein. So, kann man das ausblenden.
Cortana Button weg. Ok, das kann man irgendwie nicht weg machen. Gut, also Windows Insider
haben wir jetzt am Start. Jetzt können wir jetzt L-Installation, da brauch ich erstmal
die Anleitung für. Das kann ich mir immer nicht zählen. Das kann ich mir immer nicht
merken. Mal ganz schnell in den Chat gucken. Was hab letztens aus dem Wertstoffhof einen
PC mit i7 6700? Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht. Gar nicht mal so übel. Ja, ich im Prinzip
auch. Das ist nämlich die Sache. Es gibt ja diese Sorte von YouTube Content eigentlich
nicht mehr. Neues Feature, Wetter in der Taskliste. Ja, also Microsoft fällt auch nichts mehr
ein, ne? Den fällt echt auch nichts mehr ein. Ok, also WSL 2 Install Anleitung brauch ich.
Installieren. Gibt es das auch? Please auf Englisch. Simplify Install. WSL minus, minus
Install. Ok. Alles klar. Nochmal probieren wir das mal aus. Wie sieht die Systemsteuerung
aus? Noch genauso wie vorher. Und das auch noch fast so wie vorher. Also den gleichen
Crap gibt es immer noch. So, also jetzt soll ich machen WSL Install. Muss man das in der
PowerShell machen? Wahrscheinlich. Ah! Gebaidet! Powerpoint! Ihr habt es genau gesehen, ich
wollte da nicht draufdrücken, aber. Ich wollte da eigentlich die PowerShell starten. PowerShell.
Nein, dann Powerpoint ist nicht preinstall. Ah. Moment, wir sind nicht unter Linux, ne?
Das geht. Kekwate? Kekwate? Ah, ne. Moment, das hat so lange gebraucht, mir zu sagen,
dass es das Programm nicht gibt, oder was? Alter, das ist so fail. Standardmäßig Out-of-the-Box
Shell unter Windows. Ist der Wahnsinn. Ok. Jetzt geht's los. Jetzt gibt's Whizzle. Ok,
da müssen wir das gleich noch auf GitHub aufmachen und gucken, wer ist LG. Mal schauen,
wie man den Kram installiert. Ja, G-Sodo ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch. Ok, Treiber installieren
können wir nicht, weil wir weder AMD noch Intel noch Nvidia haben in der VM. Ah, minus
D Ubuntu hätte ich machen müssen, ok. Kann ich hier immer noch. Ich glaube, das ist doch,
ich wollte gerade sagen, Ubuntu ist doch sogar Standard. Leute, sorry, ich spreche da immer
falsch aus. Ich spreche da immer, ist ja immer falsch, wie ich es ausspreche, ne? Richtige
Aussprache, wissen wir alle, ist. So, ist es successful? Ok, das haben wir jetzt gemacht.
Reboot when prompted, ok. Passiert da jetzt das gleiche? No action is taken. Ok, also
Reboot. Ich starte. Es ist ja immer noch Windows. Wenn man Kali installiert, flaggt Windows
Defender das als Virus. Das verstehe ich sogar, weil da garantiert so viel Testzeug drinne
ist, wo jedes Signatur-based Virenscanner 50.000 mal triggert. Allerdings solltest du, wenn
du Kali runterlädst, auch in der Lage sein, sowas zu ignorieren. Cottbus 99, tja. Schule
allein bringt es da nicht. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass Ausbildung im Betrieb es großartig
wirklich bringt, aber zumindest hat man da ein bisschen Praxisbezug. Was hast du denn
gelernt? Also, welche Sorte ist das? Welches Informatiker-Flavor hättest du bei der Microsoft-Seite
herunterscrollen müssen? Da stand auch die Anleitung, falls du es per Porsche... ja, wurscht.
Informatiker für Game- und Multimedia-Entwicklung. Ok, nice. Hab ich schon nie was von gehört.
Dann hast du zumindest schon mal ein Zettel. Also, haben wir gemacht. After-Reboot-Installation
will continue. Ah, siehst du mal. Leute, ich hab' schneller auf und lese was passiert,
bevor Windows das selbst macht. Jetzt wird Jubandu installiert. Muss ich irgendwas Spezielles
beachten? These will be your Linux Credentials. Moment. Das ist jetzt... Moment, WSLG ist
automatisch mitinstalliert jetzt? Wirklich? Ok, das probieren wir jetzt gleich aus. Ok.
Test 123456 123456. Das wäre natürlich nice. Das wäre natürlich äußerst nice. So, da
machen wir das doch mal. Sudo-Update. Dann machen wir erstmal mal ein Upgrade, um auf
Nummer sicher zu gehen. By the way, kann der Microsoft-Paket-Manager eigentlich mittlerweile
Pakete deinstallieren? Wir kecken mal ne Runde wieder auf GitHub, während das installiert.
Was? Wie der... Echt? Kann der das mittlerweile? Da haben die jetzt ein Jahr für gebraucht,
oder? Nee, das geht immer noch nicht. Oder? Nee, das geht immer noch nicht. Ja, das geht
immer noch nicht. Das geht immer noch nicht. Das ist so fail. Microsoft-Logik, Alter. Nein,
wir installieren garantiert nicht GIMP. So, wir machen jetzt erstmal ein Update vom installierten
Ubuntu und installieren mal die neue Windows-Shell. Wie ging das noch mal? Windows-Terminal-Install?
Musste man das über den Store machen? Das muss man über den Store machen irgendwie.
Ich kann mich dunkel dran erinnern. Ich finde das so geil, dass das einfach 73.000 Sterne
hat. 73.000 Sterne haben normalerweise nur sonst richtig geile, huge Projekte. Und da
sieht man mal, die Leute sind so... Die haben so gelecht nach einem ordentlichen Windows-Terminal,
weil das eingebaute einfach abgrundtiefer Schrott ist, dass sie sogar jetzt ein halbwegs
brauchbares Terminal, also das erste halbwegs brauchbare Terminal für Windows absolut krass
abfeiern. Ok, man muss über den Store gehen. Er runterladen, jawoll. Ist gut. Oh. Das ist
das einzige, was ich wahrscheinlich jemals über den Microsoft-Store installieren werde.
Nehm die Store-Preview. Warum fängt es jetzt einfach schon an? Calcuate. Ok, ok, wo ist
die... Wo ist die... Wo ist die... Preview? Preview? Ja. Installieren wir einfach beides.
Es ist kaputt, Leute. Ah, jetzt geht's. So. Ok. Ok, es startet sich automatisch. Aber
die haben den neuen Microsoft-Fond drinnen, ne? Was haben wir hier? Terminal und Terminal.
By the way, was ist es denn jetzt? Ist das jetzt die Preview, oder was ist das? Jetzt
weiß man wieder nicht, was das ist. Ah, hier, das ist Preview. Pin to Taskbar. Ganz den
Shit hier unten entfernen. Bäm. Bäm. Bäm. Ist das jetzt eigentlich WSL2 oder WSL1? Es
müsste WSL2 sein jetzt. Ich glaube, das Umstellen muss man nicht immer machen. Äh, wie kann
man das eigentlich checken? Check if WSL1 or 2. How do I know? How do I... Hm? Click
in window searcher type version. Hä? Was? Und da steht jetzt was von WSL drin, oder was?
She baited. Dieses, dieses, dieses Dinger. WSL list minus minus all. Ah, der Chat, Chat
ist für der Big Brain. Naja, aber das ist nicht die WSL-Version. Fair. WSL minus minus
help. Nope. She baited. Nee, nee, ich schreibe keine 10 Finger. Nicht wirklich, also ein
bisschen, aber nicht wirklich gut. Ah, hier, version 2, da steht es doch. Version 2, okay,
wir haben das aktuelle. Exquisite. Okay, also wir haben es jetzt installiert. Das bedeutet,
jetzt können wir einfach Grafikprogramme installieren. Da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt. Also, zeige
ich mal her. Erstmal hier, ordentlich, ordentlich, ordentlich shell starten. Ach, der neue Font
ist glaube ich, ich muss mal gucken, ist das jetzt der neue Microsoft Font schon? Wenn
ja, finde ich den eigentlich ganz, ganz hübsch. Ach nee, warte mal, Font-Settings muss man
mit dem Datei machen, dann kann ja nachkommen. Also, jetzt können wir Grafikprogramme installieren,
sonst brauchen wir anscheinend nichts. Okay, probieren wir mal aus. Also das wichtigste
ist, wir installieren XIs. XIs ist das Allerwichtigste. Ohne XIs geht da gar nichts. Yes. Die Preview
hat einen Settings-Panel, das ist die Preview, die ich laufen habe. Ach hier, guck mal. Ah,
da kann man die Schrift nicht einstellen. Massive Settings-Panel, huge. Das hat sich
jetzt echt gelohnt, dass das ein Settings-Panel hat dafür. Ach, Moment, nee, ich hab nichts
gesagt, Leute, es ist gut. Ja, ja, ist gut, Chat, Chat, Chat, ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Also, Interaction, Appearance, Dark, wichtig. Color. Okay. Aber mit Schrift gibt's da trotzdem
nichts, oder? Oder hat jemand was von Font gesehen? Na gut. Oh, guck mal, Dark Mode,
Massive Poggers. So, also, da können wir das jetzt mal ausprobieren. Also, XIs. Guck mal
mal. Wichtigste Anwendung aller Zeiten und Select as Fuck. Guck mal, X ist kaputt, wenn
man außerhalb von Windows, Lul, XIs procken. Direkt, direkt procken. Direkt procken, es
kriegt keine Events von Windows Desktop. GLX Gears. GLX Gears wird nicht funktionieren,
da muss man glaub ich Mesatools oder so installieren. Ich denke mal, GLX Gears wird nicht funktionieren.
Oh. Hallo. Oh, procken. Oh, Massive. Massive FPS, Alter. Huge FPS. Huge FPS. Huge FPS.
Warte mal, GLX Gears, VSync off. Jetzt kann ich mir immer nicht merken, wie das funktioniert.
Genau. Und jetzt bekommen wir, wie viel FPS? 800 FPS. Oh. Aber Fullscreen funst nicht.
Super ToxCard. Jawoll. Das liegt jetzt aber auch schon ein bisschen an der VM, ne? Gehe
auf ein Profil und dann auf Darstellung. Du meinst jetzt hier im... Ah, das ist Cascadia
Mono. Genau, das wollte ich nachkommen. Das ist das Neue. Jaja, wir sind in der VM. Also,
daran wird es wahrscheinlich liegen, dass es jetzt so kacke funktioniert. Installier mal
Wine. Das haben wir das letzte Mal tatsächlich sogar gemacht. Ok, also das funktioniert jetzt.
Jetzt kann ich nämlich ein paar Sachen probieren, die ich schon die ganze Zeit probiere. Also
erstmal abinstallen. Erstmal in Firefox gucken, wie gut das funst. Chrome können wir ja nicht
installieren unter Ubuntu, weil das ein komisches, hässliches Snap ist und das funktioniert
nicht. Was auch immer die sich dabei gedacht haben. Guck, deswegen laden die hier Chrome
runter und installieren Chrome nicht über den Package Manager. Wine funktioniert, das
haben wir das letzte Mal ausprobiert. Microsoft Teams. Edge Browser für... Ernsthaft? Die
wollen mir ernsthaft erzählen, ich soll Edge installieren. Edge für Linux unter WSL in
Windows. Sollen wir das mal machen? Ah, komm. Firefox install ist schon mal huge langsam.
Aber wir können bei der Gelegenheit... Warum ist das so langsam? Weil das Ubuntu Repos
so sackte. Du willst auch Wetter in der Taskbar. Ich würde gern das Wetter wegmachen. Erstens
sieht das Kacke aus. Total schlecht anti-elast. Wie macht man das weg? Lull. Ernsthaft? Hack
wait. Was ist denn mit dem Ubuntu Server hier los? Wartet mal Leute, wir müssen mal kurz
die etc... Moment, warte. Achso, hab ich Wim installiert. Wim, etc, apt. Moment, das
Geplimmel geht mir auf den Kicks. Wir machen jetzt die Hardcore Variante. Wir stellen einfach
das Terminal, einfach den Sound aus. Get Shrecked. Sources List. Achieve Ubuntu, gibt's das?
Gibt's das auch als.de? Nein? Fuck. Ach,.de. Ach,.de. Ach,.de. Ach,.de. Ach,.de.
Ach,.de. Ach,.de. Ach,.de. Ach. So was da? Excellent. Was haben die eigentlich eigentlich
alles für 30.000 Sachen drinne.
Oh, excellent.
Up, update.
Bam, jetzt geht's hoffentlich ein bisschen schneller.
Some files. Ah, juckt mich nicht.
Firefox install,
zack. Ja, jetzt
geht's doch eine ganze Ecke schneller.
So, dann gucken wir mal, wie Firefox
läuft und dann, das eigentliche, was
ich ausprobieren will, ist
das da, weil das lief
das letzte Mal kacke und das wäre
äußerst praktisch, wenn das unter
WSL läuft, dann hätte man nämlich
die Möglichkeit, das ganze
JetBrains Talkstar zu verwenden.
So.
Also, jetzt haben wir
Firefox install, mal gucken, wie der läuft.
Wird wahrscheinlich grottenschlecht sein.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, fuck.
Warum Rider unter WSL?
Weil viele Firmen auf die
Idee kommen und den Leuten
es verbieten oder settingstechnisch
verbieten, unter Windows was zu installieren
und lustigerweise unter WSL
nicht. Okay, wir
brauchen, wir brauchen definitiv
OpenGL Beschleunigung,
sonst ist es nicht benutzbar.
Kannste komplett vergessen.
Das kannst du komplett, komplett
klicken.
Aber das Sound geht.
Leute, das Sound geht einfach.
Das ist richtig gut.
Wie sieht so die CPU-Auslastung aus?
Okay, die CPU
ist, die CPU ist dicht.
Die CPU ist mehr oder
weniger dicht.
Bei 360p CalcWake, wie
sieht es mit 1044p aus?
Okay.
RIP.
Das liegt an der VM, jaja, auf jeden
Fall liegt das an der VM.
Die schreiben ja auch hier, die schreiben ja auch
hier, man könnte
NVIDIA, Intel, AMD, GPU,
etwas installieren. Das bringt uns halt an der Stelle
nichts, weil wir halt VMWare-Geschichte
haben. Gibt's da vielleicht
was? WSLG?
VMWare.
Aber vielleicht gibt's ja da sogar
ein extra Treiber für.
Moment, ich muss mal ein Video ausmachen, das wird mir sonst zu monack
essig.
Nee, da gibt's anscheinend
nix für.
Monack essig.
So, aber es funktioniert, also es funktioniert
besser als das andere, was wir letztens ausprobiert haben.
Einfach die VMWare-Tools in
WSL installieren, nee, das wird nicht
funktionieren.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Das ist ja ein Hyper-V unten drunter.
Der Papierkorb hat ein neues
Symbol. Oh ja, tatsächlich.
Leute, huge change. Der Papierkorb
sieht jetzt anders aus.
Pock like this.
Da hab ich drauf gewartet
die letzten 15 Jahre.
Huge, richtig.
Actually, actually huge
Leute.
Oh, jetzt hat er hier am abkacken. Okay,
JetBrains, JetBrains
Toolbox.
Runterladen, nicht als Exe, sondern
als Target Set.
So.
CD, Downloads.
Nee, Moment. Wie komme ich da jetzt
noch mal hin?
Ich kann einfach
Explorer.
Nee.
Exe? So ging das,
wenn man das von Linux aus starten will.
Genau.
Eigentlich richtig bigprank gemacht, dass du von der
Linux-Umgebung Windows-Sachen starten kannst.
Also es ist nicht alles
schlecht hier.
So, Tile, Xfz,
JetBrains.
Was auch immer der da kopiert hat,
ich weiß es nicht.
So, gucken wir, ob das
jetzt läuft. Ich meine, das ist Java gedünstet.
Oder auch nicht.
Das...
Startet einfach nicht.
Gut.
Next.
Das funktioniert schon mal nicht.
Dann downloaden wir
Rider direkt, würde ich sagen. Start
noch mal. Ganzes bringt
was.
Das schreibt noch nicht mal
irgendeine Hilfe-Ding hin.
Das startet einfach
und kackt ab. Pass mal auf
S-Trace. Bam.
Ah, yes, alles klar.
Äh, irgendwie
D-Bus oder sonst wie.
Weiß nicht, was der für Schmerzen hat. Wir
downloaden einfach
Jetzt ist alles klar, hoffe ich mal.
Rider
Download. Also das haben wir das letzte Mal zum Starten
bekommen, aber es war...
Es war unbenutzbar.
30 Tage Trial.
Ach ja, Linux ist in dem Fall
dafür auch besser, weil man dort
einfach die Trial resetten kann als unter
Windows. Was wir natürlich niemals
machen werden und ich keinen
anstiften möchte dazu.
Sowas gehört sich ja nicht.
Richtig kacke
Can't wait.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt
startet. Ich fürchte aber, dass
das auch nicht starten wird, wenn die Toolbox
schon nicht startet.
XFZV
30 Milliarden Sachen, das halbe
Internet wird unpackt.
Leute, es sind wieder richtig huge viele Leute
am Start. Das ist richtig poggers.
Schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Wie habt ihr euren Weg
hierher gefunden? Würde mich mal interessieren. Über
YouTube? Über die Twitch-Empfehlung?
Wie seid ihr hergekommen?
Discord. Okay, das ist auch
eine Möglichkeit. YouTube, YouTube.
Nice.
Discord-Benachrichtigung. Ja, gut.
CD-Bin. Also,
zeig mal her.
Rider-SH.
Oh, oh, das macht was, das macht was.
Post-Champ. Wie das?
Ernsthaft? Rider
startet, aber die Toolbox nicht?
Ihr seid über meinen OnlyFans hergekommen?
Okay, das kann ich mir...
Hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, aber...
Also, aber nicht leaken, Leute.
Nicht leaken, ja. Die Videos
gibt's nur nach Bezahlung.
Wer liegt, gleich spannen.
So,
Dark.
Das funktioniert. Das läuft
sogar schon mal ganz gut.
Sind die Explorer? Sind die Explorer?
Ist das neu? Ach, das ist neu!
Guckt mal da, lasst mal vergleichen.
Guckt mal.
Sollte ich euch mal was sagen? Normalerweise
bin ich ja da sehr konservativ, was solche
Changes angeht. Die neuen Icons
sind viel besser aus als die alten.
Viel besser.
True.
Ist wieder
Geschmackssache, ja. Gerade
sowas, da scheinen sich ja die Geister dran.
HugeFont-Rendering
haben wir hier.
Das Font-Rendering ist ja hier exquisite.
.NET Core not installed.
Macht ja nichts.
Next.
Evaluate.
Okay.
Es ist wieder gecrashed, Leute.
Es ist gestartet und gecrashed.
CrashChamp.
Jetzt geht's. Jetzt geht's.
NewSolution.
Es laggt, aber
es ist.
Install, missing,
compound. Kann man jetzt über
Rider nachinstallieren?
Neger.
Ja, gut. Dann installieren wir
erst mal ein.NET Core hier drunter.
Schau mal unten rechts beim kleinen Fall,
ob dort ein Icon für die Toolbox ist.
Nö.
Was denn das?
Ach, das übliche Windows-Gestellte.
Nee, gibt keinen Toolbox.
Mit Grafiktreiber, glaube ich, tatsächlich läuft das
ganz gut. Wir probieren das aus.
Also wir probieren das aus auf einer
Kiste mit
mit Grafiktreiber. Spätestens wenn
das Ding nicht mehr Beta ist, aber ansonsten
hole ich vielleicht mal irgendeine olle
Kiste mit Grafikkarte hier raus und probieren
das aus.
Was wollte ich jetzt machen, Leute?
Voll vergessen.
Ach so,.NET Core install.
.NET Core install script
Linux.
Yep. GIF
Sage-Dash
Äh
Bash.
Wir können es auch als Snap installieren,
Leute.
A mir ist es lieber, ich installiere das
so, bevor ich mir das mit irgendeinem Snap
installiere. Ich hasse Snapchat.
Weiß nicht, ob's noch
jemt, so geht. Haben wir
SnapFans?
Die 3.1?
Ach ne, da muss man Channel angeben, ne? Channel, Channel Stable. Stable, ne. Minus was muss man
dann machen? Ah, nur Minus Channel, ja Microsoft kann schon mal wieder an nichts halten, ja.
Stable, klein. Ne, meine Güte. Channel, wie geht das nochmal?
Current, Current, Current. Nicht Stable. Du hast dein Ubuntu über Snap installiert.
Excellent. Snap ist das Beste. Ja, ja. Chat, ich glaub's euch, ja. Du kannst das mit über
App, ach so,.NET, ne kannst du nicht, das haben die nicht drinne. Was ich übrigens tatsächlich
nicht verstehe, weil die sind ja, die sind ja so fett Microsoft-Partner. Aber.NET.com sind
nicht drinne, versteh ich nicht. Was ist Snap? Snap ist das Ubuntu-Docker. Es hat ein bisschen
andere Philosophie dahinter und so wie typische, die typischen Ubuntu-Alleingänge irgendwie
sucks. So, also jetzt haben wir.NET installiert. Jetzt können wir hier auch mal reingehen.
Downloads. Rider. Bin. So, und jetzt können wir mal schauen, ob wir ein.NET-Projekt anlegen
können, ob sich das bedienen lässt. Die arbeiten mit Microsoft nur für Geld zusammen, ja gut.
Aber vielleicht bekommen sie ja Geld dafür, das ins Repo zu machen. Dass sie das nicht
aus reiner Nächstenliebe machen, ist uns glaub ich allen klar. So,.NET 5, bla bla bla,
Console Lab 1, perfekt. Okay Leute, ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen, dass es besser läuft
als das letzte Mal. Keine Native Keychain und auch keine Native Blockchain, unbrauchbar.
Uninstall. Leute, Leute, das ist milliardenfach besser als das letzte Mal. Wenn die noch einen
ordentlichen Grafikkartentreiber haben, dann läuft das auch ganz gut. Ich mein, das hier
ist alles Software-Rendering bei mir, was ich hier hab. Alles Software-Rendering. Aber
das funktioniert, das funktioniert relativ gut. Das könnte tatsächlich was taugen, ehrlich
gesagt. Ja, das könnte ehrlich was taugen. Ich mein, es tippt sich ein bisschen laggy,
und so. Aber kein Vergleich zu dem Crap vom letzten Mal. Vollkommen in Ordnung. Also,
mit einem ordentlichen Grafikkarttreiber. Ich würd's ja gerne ausprobieren, kann ich halt
nicht, weil das hier nur eine VM ist. Aber ich bin, das finde ich schon mal gut. Jetzt
probieren wir noch mal was, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das geht. Install, wird Manager,
wir installieren jetzt nur eine VM. Wir installieren uns eine VM in einer VM in einer VM. Das kann
eigentlich nicht funktionieren. Es geht eigentlich nicht. Hast du schon gehört, dass man demnächst
reine X und MSX Sachen in den Windows Store packen kann? Ja, das wird aber auch nicht
dazu führen, dass mehr Leute Windows Store verwenden, weil der Windows Store suckt. Wir
hätten ein UI-Update geben für den Windows Store. Ja, das wird ihn auch nicht besser
machen. Wisst ihr was Microsoft seit Jahren, die letzten 10 Jahre verkackt? Die kriegen
es nicht hin, eine ordentliche UI-Technologie für Windows rauszubringen, wo Leute mit Anwendung
entwickeln können. Der letzte Hit von Microsoft ist, also der vorletzte Hit von Microsoft
war ja UWP, also zum Beispiel das, wo der Windows Taschenrechner drin programmiert
ist. Diese huge Augenweide von einem Programm. Das war der letzte Geniestreich von Microsoft,
UWP. Hat sich nie so richtig durchgesetzt, gerade wegen der Sandbox und weil viele Leute
halt was machen wollten, was nicht geht. Du kannst, glaube ich, bis heute noch keine
richtigen Screenshots von UWP machen und so was. Und danach haben sie sich überlegt,
Microsoft, Massive Brain Idee. Wir machen WinUI. WinUI ist dann angeblich das Zusammenführen
von allen Windows GUI-Technologien unter einem neuen Ding. Aber jetzt hat man sich dafür
entschieden, man unterstützt im Prinzip auch nur die ganze UWP-Sache und sonst nichts,
bis Future Releases. Was dann im Endeffekt dazu führt, dass es auch sackt. Die hätten
WinUI für Unpackaged Apps machen müssen und alles wäre gut, aber nein, wollen sie
nicht. Okay, Wirt Manager startet schon mal. Jetzt waren wir in der VM, in der VM, in der
VM. Big, big brain poggers. Wie ging das nochmal? Add Connection? Koemu? Ah nee, okay, müssen
wir erst noch installieren. Also. Hat WSLK VM oder ich habe keine Ahnung, das probiere
ich jetzt gerade aus. Was muss man da, lib-wirt muss man da glaube ich installieren, ne? lib-wirt.
KVM? Nee. KVM okay. KVM Accelerations can be used. Also das meint es geht. Was muss
man da überhaupt installieren? Okay. Ubuntu install KVM. Zeig her. Chubuntu. Paste. Okay,
das funktioniert. Haben wir gemacht. Okay, den ganzen Shit muss ich installieren, alles
klar, mache ich jetzt. Yes. Add users to group. Ja, das machen wir gleich, das machen wir
gleich. Aber man muss das doppelt machen, okay. So, sudo, wir starten den Wirt Manager
einfach als sudo, easy. Okay. Add Connection, local. Not connected. Ah, ich muss es noch
starten, ne? System CTL start lib-wirt d. Oh nee. Ach Moment, ich kann es nicht starten,
weil kein System d drauf ist. Sollte es jetzt ernsthaft an System d scheitern, ja? Ha,
wir können es einfach so starten, gebaited. Huge gebaited. So, tmax, das war auch was,
paar mehr Terminals haben können. So, lib-wirt, jetzt bin ich echt gespannt, ob der Kram
funktioniert. Wenn das jetzt klappt, dann beiß ich mir in Bob's. Äh, Moment, Moment,
Moment, geht das? Geht das ernsthaft? Ich kann ernsthaft eine KVM-VM unter, da kann
man nicht mal von nested-virtualisierung sprechen, das ist hyper nested-virtualisierung. Okay,
jetzt muss ich mir erstmal Ubuntu ISO downloaden. Ubuntu ISO download, das ist irgendwas, wobei
wir installieren nicht Ubuntu, das ist glaube ich zu fett. Wir können Windows in KVM installieren.
Nein, das machen wir nicht. Das machen wir nicht, das ist Two-Paints-Champ. Das ist
Two-Paints-Champ. Wir installieren, ach komm, wir installieren jetzt Ubuntu ISO, download,
fertig. Accept, download, jawoll. Windows XP, das ist eine gute Idee, wir installieren
Windows XP, das ist eine Poggers-Idee. Windows XP ISO. 64, Moment, 64 bringt nix. Nee, nee,
Windows, Windows, Windows XP 32 ISO. Hat jemand, hat jemand einen exzellenten ISO Download?
ISO Driver, oh ja, das klingt äußerst, das klingt äußerst vertrauenserwenkend. Wie
fasiert bist du mit Kuba? Nee, das war nicht wirklich großartig. Wir hatten doch letztens
ein Windows ISO. Moment, Moment. Internet, Arschchei, Windows XP. Nee, das habe ich gelöscht.
Ja, bam. Da ist es. Gab es ernsthaft einen Service Pack 3? Oh nein, Siri leaked. Wo kann
man das jetzt downloaden? Leute, wo ist der, wo ist der, ah hier, ISO Fall. Okay, also
nur mal, dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe. Wir installieren jetzt Windows XP in KVM unter
WSL, was selbst in Hyper-V läuft, in einer Windows, auf einem Windows Host, der in KVM-Ware
auf einem Windows Host läuft. Na easy, das, was soll denn schon schief gehen, Leute? Was
soll denn schon schief gehen? Okay, okay. Wir machen jetzt Trick 17. Wir beschleunigen
den Download jetzt, indem wir uns hier den Download-Link nehmen, das abbrechen, beinstallieren,
wo wir wieder sehen, ist einfach besser, wenn man ordentliche, sudo, abinstall. Wir installieren
es. Ach nee, Moment, was war das? Minus J10, LowBrain, Minus J10, nee, Minus S16, Minus
X16, okay, der Chat weiß das, ich weiß es nicht, nein. Kann es sein, dass das hier verbackt
ist? Ach nee, hier. Ah, jetzt ist das schon immer bei drei Minuten Download. Hacker,
Hacker-Man haben wir so. Okay, Heinrich, Dankeschön, Hyper-Subscription, 12 Monate. Okay, Moment,
es geht wieder hoch, es geht wieder hoch. Microsoft hat erkannt, dass wir sie chibänen.
Wobei, es geht, es geht. Also, Chat hat irgendeine Frage, habe ich gerade gesehen. Da Tiger666D,
was? WTF, was? Tiger, ich habe keine Ahnung, was du meinst. Das klingt schon abenteuerlich,
ja, das stimmt. Programmieren in Java oder C++ in C-Sharp? Beides nicht, such dir eine
ordentliche Programmiersprache raus. Also, ein Programm zum Anfangen ist eine Programmiersprache,
zum Einstieg ist C-Sharp nicht schlecht, C-Sharp, Python oder Javascript würde ich sagen oder
Go, Python, Javascript, Go oder C-Sharp, allerdings finde ich zum Einstieg Javascript am besten,
weil man eben einfach grafisch was im Browser sieht. So, Download läuft, Download von der
Ubuntu ISO sollte fertig sein. Dann probieren wir jetzt erstmal das Ubuntu System hier anzulegen.
Ich gucke nochmal kurz in Chat, ob ich irgendwelche Questions übersehen habe. Übrigens, nice,
dass so viele Leute am Start sind heute. Das ist nicht mal White Pepo Planket, das ist einfach
nur Pepo Planket, wie dem auch sei. Der hat noch nicht genug gefuttert, irgendwann wird
der White Pepo Planket. Ja, es ist wichtig, was man machen will, genau. Also je nachdem
was du vorhast, gibt es unterschiedlich sinnvolle Startwege, was Programmiersprachen angeht.
Allerdings kann ich dir nicht empfehlen, mit C, C++ anzufangen. Ich kenne aber jemand,
der ist ein großer C, C++ Fan für den Einstieg und ich werde demnächst mit jemand anderem ein
Video zusammen machen, was unserer Meinung nach die besten Programmiersprachen für den
Einstieg sind. Wir werden nehmen Javascript, Python, Go, ich werde C Sharp nehmen und er
will anscheinend, ich hoffe er nimmt C. Da gehe ich nämlich noch mit. C++ ist fragwürdig.
C finde ich nicht schlecht, Patrick. Sehe ich auch so. Gerade auf Plattformen, wo du keine
andere Wahl hast. Also wenn du mit irgendwelchen Microcontroller Zeug anfangen willst, ist
das the way, the way ist das. Dankeschön für die Subs, wen haben wir hier? W, ich kann
immer reden, Leute. Fspunkelp, nein das heißt wahrscheinlich fspunklp, aber die andere fand
ich auch nicht schlecht. Ekorp, Prime Subscriptions hier, Dankeschön für die Subs, Leute. Habe
ich es gemacht, ist aber schon eine ganze Weile her. Falls mich jemand, irgendjemand hat mich
doch gefragt, wo ich das alles gelernt habe, ne? Ach nee, der meint es, Chain Law. Also
ich habe das einfach nur über die letzten Jahre mehr oder weniger einfach durch machen
gelernt, ja. Ok, aber der Download ist zumindest schneller als das andere. Also legen wir mal
eine VM an. Leute, ich bin immer noch ungläubig, ob der Kram jetzt funktioniert. Also New,
ISO, Choose Media, Install. Moment, kann man da was Neues hinzufügen? Browse. Ok, das leckt
ein bisschen. Ok, dann nehme ich jetzt meinen Windows Download Ordner dafür. Mount, C,
Ach du Scheiße. Ok, das ist jetzt Big Brain. Tests, Downloads, und da sollte ich jetzt
mein Ubuntu ISO haben. Ok, das ist Big Brain, dass das funktioniert. Ok, jetzt haben wir
aber, jetzt sind wir komplett einmal durch den Stack durch, von oben nach unten. Eigentlich
ohne Scheiß, Leute. Weißt du, was ich machen müsste? Ich müsste ein Schertverzeichnis
machen von meinem Host. Ich müsste ein Schertfolder machen von meinem Host und dort das Windows
ISO reinlegen. Dann wäre komplett vorbei. Ok, also wir haben hier Ubuntu ISO, Choose.
Eine VM in einer VM in einer VM oder habe ich, nee, es ist eine VM in einer VM in einer
VM. Also es ist Windows Host mit Windows Guest mit Ubuntu Guest mit Ubuntu Guest. Prediction,
ich predikte, dass das funktioniert. Ah, wollen wir Prediction? Leute, haben wir Mod
Check? Mod Check? Können wir Prediction machen, dass die Leute ein bisschen ihre Channel Punkte
ausgeben können? Die Leute wollen ihre Channel Punkte ausgeben. Ich glaube, Slash, Patrick,
ich bin da auch zu dumm für, ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert. SlashPoll ist es nicht,
das ist glaube ich SlashVote? Nee, war das doch SlashPoll? SlashPrediction? Ah, SlashPrediction
ist es. Warte mal, SlashPrediction? Ok. Vorhersage starten. Vorhersage benennen. Wird die VM in
einer VM laufen? Ergebnis ja, nein. Vorhersage starten. Zack. Die Vorhersage läuft, ihr könnt
euch das jetzt überlegen. Könnt ihr ein paar eurer Channel Punkte loswerden. Denkt dran,
die Chancen, dass es nicht geht, sind auch durchaus vorhanden, ja. Also. Achso, Selecto
ist besser. Jubandu. Noch geht es ja nicht los, ja. Zwei CPUs, Memory, passts. Ja. Passts.
Ok. Was sagt die Abstimmung? Wie ist die Abstimmung ausgegangen? SlashPrediction? Also, 66% sagen
ja, 34% sagen nein. Ok, schauen wir mal. 30 Sekunden, 30 Sekunden Abstimmung muss reichen.
Finish. Ok, es funktioniert. Funktioniert anscheinend nicht. Wird LockD? Moment, das
liegt daran, dass ich irgendwas nicht gestartet habe, oder? Aber es funktioniert nicht. Wird
Lock. Muss ich das so starten? Also ich werde jetzt auf jeden Fall die Prediction schon mal
machen, dass es nicht funktioniert hat. Aber vielleicht geht es jetzt nachdem ich, nachdem
ich. Ja, jetzt geht es, aber das war ja nicht für uns weg der Sache. Ich kann jetzt nicht
das noch mal ändern. So, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt geht. Nein, geht immer noch
nicht. RIP, Leute, RIP. Muss ich das vielleicht als Hut starten? Nope, keine Chance, Leute.
Es läuft nicht. Kann man denn? Das ist jetzt ein bisschen ärgerlich, ne? Fail to connect.
Ja, ja, schön, aber das kann ich ja nicht machen. Ich habe ja kein System D. Ich habe
ja kein System D, das funktioniert nicht. Hä? Ok, nice. Wenn man es richtig startet,
funktioniert es. Exzellent, exzellent. Gut zu wissen. Wir haben noch vor allem, die läuft.
Ich bin begeistert. So, wie starten wir jetzt von der CD? No media selected. Ich habe es
doch eben gerade ausgewählt. Naja. No bootable device. Alter, was? Wo ist dein Problem? Ok,
boot options von CD booten, please. Yes. Nee, nee, nee, Punkt zurück gibt es nicht. Wir
haben abgestimmt und es ging nicht. Ich will jetzt noch, dass der von der CD bootet. Boote
von der CD. Starte das verdammte Spiel. Ha. Jubando. Oh, es ist langsam, Leute. Es ist
fucking langsam. Es ist massive langsam. Voller CPU-Auslastung, Crash. Ok. Oh, fuck.
Ok, RIP. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob wir Windows XP zum Laufen kriegen, Klai. Wo, was macht
der Windows XP Download? Windows XP Download immer noch acht Minuten. 73%. Da startet
was, Leute. Postchamp. Da startet was. Wir cancelen das natürlich. Lass es doch nicht
durchlaufen. Cancel. Cancel. Hast du in VMW erlaubt? Ja, korrekt. Hab ich, sonst würde
es nicht funktionieren. Genau. Und jetzt das ganze noch in Wine. Docker in Wine in KVM.
Ne. Wait. Ne, Moment mein. Ubuntu in der VM und darin Wine. Und darin Wine in der VM.
Und dann, und dann Notepad starten. Ok, aber das ist unbenutzbar langsam gerade. Alter,
kann ich jetzt mal die Windows XP Installation mal busy-busy hinne machen. 77%. Virtualbox
fehlt noch. Wir könnten gucken, ob er Virtualbox installiert bekommt. Ok, also das ist, das
würde funktionieren, aber ich mach das mal aus. Das ist sinnlos. Kriegen wir Virtualbox
installiert? KegWaite. Wartet mal, wartet mal. Abinstall wird Virtualbox. Was ist denn
hier wildes? Ganz, ganz merkwürdige Dinger. Windows in VMWer mit WSL und dort in KVM jetzt
ein Ubuntu. Einfach nur um zu gucken, ob grafische Anwendungen funktionieren. Man muss sagen,
der Scheiß funktioniert echt ganz gut. So und wenn ich mir jetzt überlege, das noch
mit ordentlichen Grafiktreibern ist das echt ganz gut benutzbar. Also da muss man, da muss
man echt, ihr wisst, ich lob Microsoft ungern, aber ich glaube, da muss man echt Microsoft
mal loben für. Tatsache, no joke KegWaite. Aber erstmal abwarten, bis es released ist
und ich es auf der Kiste ausprobiert habe, die keine VM ist, weil in der VM ist es halt
immer kacke, sowas auszuprobieren. Es geht halt nur mit Windows Insider, deswegen musste
ich es in der VM installieren. Aber was würdest du damit machen? Zum Beispiel Rider auf der
Arbeit verwenden unter Windows. Wann wird das released? Ich glaube, das ist noch nicht
raus. So Virtualbox starten, wird, wird, wird, Virtualbox tatsächlich gestartet. Ok, kann
ich jetzt auch was anlegen? Ah, Moment. Ja, das wird nicht, ne, ne, ne, ok, Kernelmodule
wird nicht funktionieren. Kernelmodule wird nicht funktionieren, das glaube ich nicht.
Das, das glaube ich nicht, dass es funktionieren würde. Ich glaube, Virtualbox geht, geht
da nicht. Rider gibt es auch für Windows, das stimmt, allerdings gibt es viele Unternehmen,
die der Meinung sind, ihren Usern unter Windows die Installation zu verbieten, aber WSL geht
dann. Frag mich nicht, warum man das macht, aber das ist der Fall. Weil sie die Leute
behindern wollen beim Arbeiten, sodass mehr Kosten entstehen, keine Ahnung. Sag mal,
Blue Media, habe ich dir das Hetzner Sponsorship zu verdanken? Warst du nicht derjenige, der
bei Hetzner arbeitet? Irgendeiner von euch Leute arbeitet bei Hetzner und hat der Hetzner
Marketing Abteilung Bescheid gesagt, sie sollen mich mal anschreiben. Ich, ich weiß der komplette
Chat ist es wieder gewesen. Irgendeiner von euch war es aber. Virtualbox WSL. Oh. Oh.
Moment. Es gibt Virtualbox Versionen, die. Moment, es gibt Virtualbox Versionen, die
unterstützen WSL. Was habe ich denn für eine Version? 6.1. Wait a minute. Okay, die Seite
lernt man, also vielleicht geht es ja doch. Na, das ist bescheuert. So, was macht mein
Windows XP Download? Windows XP Download in drei Minuten fertig. Okay, jetzt werden wir
überleben. Please install Virtualbox. Ich glaube, das wird einfach nicht funktionieren.
Ich glaube, es sind einfach nur Linux Headers. Einfach nur Standard-Mesh-Linux-Headers.
Nee, warte, wie ging das aus der Ubuntu nochmal? Ubuntu install Linux Headers. Musstest du
das mit un-aim machen? Ah, okay, mit un-aim. Alles klar. Install. Install. Alter, ich kann
einmal tippen. Zack. Ah, gut. Keine Chance, deswegen kann ich auch keine Kernel-Module
basteln. Alles klar. Easy. Gut. Es gibt eine üble Methode, um auch System D in WSL 2
zu bekommen. Ernsthaft? WSL 2 System D. Aha. Geht es bestimmt auf GitHub. Oh, das ist äußerst
Hacker-man-ig, glaube ich. Warte mal, gab es da nicht sowas wie WSL Genie oder so? Hieß
das nicht so Genie? Ja. Quick way into System D. Okay, genau, das habe ich letztens irgendwo
gelesen. Run System D. Installation. Nee, das machen wir jetzt nicht. Das machen wir
jetzt nicht. Das ist mir zu Hacker-man-ig. Ich will jetzt erstmal Windows XP, 19 Sekunden,
gleich ist es soweit. Gleich ist es soweit. Gleich können wir uns endlich Windows XP installieren
in einer Windows VM, in einer VM, in einer VM. Wer wollte das nicht schon immer mal
machen? Älter, Download Shibade mich nicht so. Leute, der Download Shibade mich, der
geht immer runter und dann geht er wieder hoch. Gleich haben wir es. Bäm. Okay, jetzt
haben wir es. Gut, also dann legen wir mal los. Wo haben wir es hier? Virtual Box, Wirkmanager.
Also. Hallo. Herr Quaid, wo ist er? Da. Gut, neue VM. Local Media passt. Wir browsing,
wir wollen. Was ist davon jetzt Refresh? Ach nee, Moment, das Verzeichnis stimmt ja nicht.
Jetzt wollen wir als Verzeichnis haben. Test, Downloads, nee. Moment, wohin, wohin habe
ich Windows downloadet? Hier. Alles klar. MonkaS, ich blicke nicht mehr durch. Zu viel
Zeug auf einmal. So, Windows XP ISO. Windows XP hat er erkannt. Forward 512. Konnte Windows
XP mehr als ein CPU kehren? Ja, ne? Konnten, klar, klar, konnten die das schon. Windows
98 hatte das Problem. Mit mehr als einem. Bäm, Windows XP ist am Start. Booting. Windows
XP Setup. Poggers. Pass auf, der findet jetzt die Festplatte nicht oder sowas. Irgendwas
ist da jetzt noch, das nicht funktioniert. Oh, der hat eine ganz schöne Auslastung, sage
ich euch. Schnell, schnell ist was anderes. Aber allein schon, aber ohne Mist, allein
schon, dass wir den Installationsscreen bekommen. Von der VM in der VM in der VM. Das ist ja
schon mal, ist ja schon mal was, ne? Es ist langsam, Leute, guckt euch das mal an, das
ist übertrieben langsam. Die Zukunft ist hier, genau. Muss mal kurz mein Licht einschalten.
Home Assistant, Licht, Arbeitszimmer. Ja, Licht ist an. Exzellent. Und das ganz ohne
aufstehen. Die Windows XP Installer Musik, ja, die kenne ich nur, wenn man Windows XP
geupgraded hat und den Windows Installer gestartet hat, ja. Hast du nested Virtualisierung an?
Ich habe nested Virtualisierung an, aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen, es ist eine VM, es
ist eine Hyper-V-VM und in dieser VM jetzt noch KVM. Also wenn das nicht, ist kein Wunder,
ne? Das vergisst, vergisst, Leute, das kriegen wir nicht installieren. Das dauert 5 Stunden,
bis das installiert ist. Aber ja, das KVM ist der Meinung, es ist alles okay, nested Virtualisier-
also Virtualisierung geht. Ich habe kein Poggies-Emote, was ist denn Poggies-Emote? Ne, das habe ich
nicht. Aber ich habe noch genug Emotes frei, also wenn wir unbedingt Poggies haben wollen.
Okay, Enter. Pass auf, jetzt erkennt er keine Festplatte. Doch, tatsächlich. NTFS, quick.
In der Windows XP VM bitte eine Windows 10 VM. Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht. Also
auch von der Geschwindigkeit und von der Software nicht. Warum hat der Vault dann
vorhin gewonnen, dass es- es hat der Vault gewonnen, dass es nicht ging, weil es auch
nicht ging. Und erst danach habe ich es gefixt, dass es geht. Boah, das ist- also der Speed
ist schon- ich meine, das ist ungefähr der Speed, den man hatte, 2005 oder so, wenn man
den Kram installiert hat, ne? Ne, Moment, wie konnte man das resize den ganzen Kram
hier nochmal? Es ist ungefähr die originale Windows XP Installer Experience, die wir hier
gerade haben von der Geschwindigkeit. Ich meine, das geben wir uns jetzt nicht, das
ist mega langweilig und damit anfangen kann man im Endeffekt auch nichts. Aber das Geile
ist, dass es geht. Virtualisiert, in virtualisiert, in virtualisiert. Wir können noch Wine installieren
und Notepad laufen lassen. Damals war das save langsamer. Ne, das kommt ganz gut hin.
Das kommt, das kommt echt ganz gut hin. Damals hast du das halt von einer CD installiert.
Du hast, damals hast du das jetzt halt, also in Wirklichkeit hätte ich jetzt vom Rechner
gesessen, hätte eine CD drinnen, das Laufwerk hätte gemacht und er hätte auch die Festplatte
kopiert. CD-Laufwerke waren richtig pains champ. Ich glaube, das hier wäre eine optimale
SVM, wo man die indischen Scammer-Reihen baiten müsste. Ja, Basti, genau, kann sich
dann dreimal raus hacken aus der SVM, Hackermanen. Oder einfach Spectre ausnutzen. Moment, ist
der, Leute, habt ihr das gesehen? Habt ihr das gesehen? Der ist von 47 Grad zurück auf
46, um dann wieder auf 47 zu gehen. Windows-Fortschrittsbalken. Tja, aber insgesamt muss ich echt sagen,
der Krempel funktioniert erstaunlich gut. Und für das, dass es in einer VM läuft,
wo wir überhaupt keinerlei Grafikbeschleunigung haben und es halt dementsprechend auch ruckelt
im Fullscreen, ist das vollkommen okay. Also ich gehe auch mal davon aus, es wird imnächst
VMWare-Treiber geben, könnte ich mir vorstellen. Das lassen die sich von VMWare bestimmt nicht
zweimal sagen. Also ist nicht verkehrt. Habt ihr noch ein CD-Laufwerk im Rechner? Jetzt
geht die A5, warum dann geht die A5? Also ich nicht, ich nicht. Nope, nope, nope. Okay,
ein paar haben noch was. Habt ihr im Rechner eingebaut oder habt ihr per USB? Wann kommt
der Poolstream? Haben wir, haben wir doch hier schon. Alles, alles parat. Internes DVD, okay.
Also ich hab noch nicht mal mehr USB, also ich könnte, ich könnte keine CDs mehr lesen.
Ich müsste vom Dachboden, glaube ich, noch einen ganz, ganz ollen Rechner holen, von
irgendwo, da ich CDs lesen könnte. Da würde ich mir aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich unbedingt
CDs lesen würde, würde ich mir einfach eins kaufen auf Amazon für 20 Euro. USB. Hast
du noch ein Faxgerät? Ich hab einen Drucker, der faxen kann, ja. Machst du faxen, mach
dich mit Achsen. Also ich hab einen Drucker, der faxen kann. Aber den hab ich nicht angeschlossen.
Also der könnte vom Gerät her faxen, aber der kann ich faxen, weil er nicht angeschlossen
ist. Guck mal, Highspeed Windows Installation. Ich, Leute, jetzt nennt mich, nennt mich wieder
mal Boomer, Boomer, Max und sonst was. Ich guck einfach unglaublich gerne das Windows
XP Setup an. Und das Windows 98 Setup. Ich glaube einfach, weil mich das an die Zeit
erinnert, wo ich, wo ich neu so Sachen gemacht hab. Ich mag das einfach. Auch wenn es sinnlos
ist. Ich könnte zur Entspannung, ich könnte zur Entspannung 2x am Tag Windows XP installieren
und nur wieder löschen. Ich glaub, das ist SP3. Ne, einmal am Tag könnte ich das machen.
Deutsche Behörde lieben Faxe, das stimmt. Oh, dieser Speed, Leute, seht ihr das? Diese
Performance. Chainlord spendet 100 Dollar. Alles klar. Defrag. Defrag geht in der VM
zu schnell, weil da eine SSD unten drunter ist. Gibt's für XP auch Wirt AIO-Triver? Ja,
gibt es, aber das bringt mir hier ja denke mal weniger, weil im Host ist halt auch nichts
gscheiß. Guck mal, Leute, wir haben, wir haben eine Maus. Ja, guck mal, ey, immerhin, die
moved, die moved halbwegs, halbwegs akkurat, immerhin, ja. Lacked minimal, aber, also,
ich hab schon Spiele gespielt, die mehr gelecked haben. Oh, Maus. Chico interessiert sich
nicht für Mäuse. Barbie hätte sich für Mäuse interessiert. Und ja, ich weiß, es
ist Pain's Jam, dass meine letzte Katze davor Barbie hieß, aber die hab ich nicht so benannt,
sondern die ehemalige Besitzer. Wo war Ken? Pain's Jam Joke. Ich hatte noch nie nen Kater,
ich hatte nur Katzen. 39 Minuten, nee, nee, nee, das geht. Also, entweder geht das deutlich
schneller oder viel langsamer. Ich tippe ja auf VM in der VM in der VM. Ich mein, hätte
mir 2003 oder so, wo man damit angefangen hat, mal jemand erzählt, ich installiere 2021
Windows XP in der VM in der VM in der VM, er hätte gesagt, Alter, was willst du von
mir, was ist ne VM? Damals wusste man noch nicht mal, was ne VM überhaupt ist. Massive
Performance hier. Huge Performance. Und jetzt gibt's Docker. Da hätt ich damals auch nicht
dran gedacht, wobei das ja mal ganz anderer Ansatz ist. Okay, okay, Leute, install, super,
SuperTuxKart. Okay, wir gucken, ob das wichtigste Game überhaupt auch ordentlich läuft. SuperTuxKart
muss sein. Also ich glaub, die vor allem fangen das gar nicht an zu installieren, die hat
schon keinen Bock mehr. One Copy Mode. Konnte man Windows XP von dem USB-Stick installieren?
Das ging, glaube ich, nicht so einfach. Ich hab das immer von CD installiert. Vom USB-Stick
ging, glaube ich, nur mit ganz, ganz viel Hacks. So mit einem Linux-Booten, mit einem
Crap auf dem USB-Stick, der dann Dinger macht, um dann Windows zu installen oder so. Ganz,
ganz merkwürdig. Das war echt nur für, also wirklich nur für richtig echte Hacker-Mans
Windows vom USB-Stick, Windows XP vom USB-Stick installieren. Ich mein, man war damals ja
auch schon, man war damals ja auch schon richtig Hacker-Man, wenn man Windows 98 von CD installiert
hat. Windows 98 von CD war auch nicht so einfach. Normalerweise musstest du Windows 98 von
Diskette booten, um dann auf CD zu wechseln. So, SuperTuxKart, SuperTuxKart ist am Start.
Oh nee, es geht, oder? Post-Champ? Post-Champ? Oh, das ist aber Huge-Render-Performance,
Leute. Huge-Render-Performance. Huge-Render-Performance.
Massive-Render-Performance haben wir hier. Jetzt macht's nix mehr. Jetzt hab ich gekrasht.
Oh nee. Oh, diese Performance, Leute. Diese Performance. Aber es läuft schon mal. 3 FPS,
ja. Wait a minute. Options, wir machen die Grafik, wir machen die Auflösung kleiner.
Moment, kann man die Auflösung, ich muss die Auflösung kleiner machen, Leute. Die
Auflösung ist zu groß. Zu... Die Auflösung ist zu groß. Kann man, und ich beende das
noch mal, kann man das hier resizen irgendwie? Nee, vergiss es. Vergiss es. Moment, man kann
das online spielen. Graphics. Okay. Advanced Pipeline off. Animated Characters off. Texture
Compression off. Particle Effects off. Quality very low. Very low. Okay, apply. Okay, kleinere
Auflösung geht nicht. Geht das nicht? Okay, das geht echt nicht noch kleiner. Das Problem
ist gar nicht so, dass es zu langsam läuft. Dadurch, dass es Software-Rendering ist, dauert
es halt langsam. Äh, what? Woa, woa, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute,
Leute, Leute. High Speed. High Speed. Die Windows XP Install läuft noch, ja. Massive,
Massive! Huge FPS!
Krasse FPS, oder?
Oh!
Massive, mehr, also.
Das, mehr geht ja nicht.
Was haben wir denn, 11 FPS?
Wahnsinn.
Und überhaupt kein Input lag.
Überhaupt kein Input lag.
Und erst klassische Graphics hier.
Also, pass mal auf.
Alter, der Input lag ist so krass.
Leute, warte mal, ich drücke jetzt mal an den Tasten, ihr hört es jetzt, guckt.
Aber easy erster Platz.
Easy win.
Guckt euch mal das Schiff an, das ist.
Alter, was sind das für Robben?
Ist das euer Ernst?
Owned, owned, owned, Alter.
Massive Robbe.
Lebens echt.
Wie im Zoo.
Ja.
Dank Corona kann man nicht in Zoo, aber man kann Supertuxkart spielen.
Okay.
Aus damit, weg, weg.
Was macht, was macht die, die XP-Installation ist losgelaufen in der Zwischenzeit, wo wir Supertuxkart gespielt haben.
Poggers.
Vielleicht sollte ich die, die XP-Installation noch mal ausmachen und gucken, ob es dann besser läuft.
Okay, die XP-Installation ist bescheuert, aber es funktioniert prinzipiell, ja.
Es funktioniert prinzipiell, okay, jetzt noch mal, noch mal die Supertuxkart Performance checken.
Es ist kaputt, Leute.
Es ist kaputt, Leute. Supertuxkart RIP. Oh.
Guck mal, Leute, wir haben 13, 14 FPS, das ist jetzt so, das, guck mal, das ist jetzt so fast flüssig.
Fast flüssig. Das ist sogar spielbar. 15 FPS, das ist sogar spielbar. Ich mein, das ist, das ist schon okay, was Microsoft da gebastelt hat und wir haben noch keinen Grafik-Treiber installiert, dass es irgendwie schneller, schneller OpenGL rendern würde.
Okay, wirklich aimen mit den Dingern kann man nicht.
Oh, ich dachte, man kann nach hinten aimen. Was passiert, wenn man ins Wasser fährt?
Okay. Alles klar, nice. Wunderbar, ich bin begeistert, Leute. Exquisite.
Exquisite. Ich würde sagen, der Test, der Test war ja mal, war wirklich huge erfolgreich.
Wie viele Stunden arbeitest du die Woche? Ich arbeite, das ist eine gute Frage, ich glaube 30 Stunden.
Also ich arbeite vier Tage, in der Regel so von 7.30 Uhr, 8 Uhr bis 16 Uhr.
Was sind denn das? 8 x 4? Warum kann Google das nicht rechnen? Ich kann 8 x 4 nicht im Kopf rechnen.
Warum kann Google das nicht rechnen?
32. Ah, jetzt verstehe ich. Quickmaps. Leute, ich weiß, dass das 32 ist. Meine Güte.
Also als könnte ich gerade als Informatik-Stellzahler die ganzen Achterpotenzen da nicht.
8 x 16, 32. Mal gucken, wie weit komme ich denn? 8 x 16, 32, 64, 128, 256, 512, 1024, 2048, 4096, 8192?
Und danach habe ich keine Ahnung mehr. 16384. Ja, ich arbeite aber nur 30 Stunden, weil es sind bei
mir nicht 8 Stunden, sondern es sind irgendwie 7,42, so was ganz scheppes sind das irgendwie.
7,5 oder so. Ja, 7,5 sind es am Tag. Also ich arbeite 30 Stunden.
Das sind Zweierpotenzen, das ist richtig. Aber da hätte ich auch von 2 bzw. von 4 anfangen müssen.
Was? 7,5? Ja, bei uns sind es 7,5. Also ich komme auf genau 30 Stunden lieber.
Reicht mir auch. Reicht mir auch. Also ich hätte gar keinen Bock mehr arbeiten zu gehen.
Deswegen Leute, müsst ihr mir alle euren Prime-Sub geben, ist ja klar. Sonst kann ich meine Internetrechnung nicht mehr bezahlen.
Ich bin richtig arm dran.
Chef guckt zu. Das kann tatsächlich sein, dass der zuguckt. Der guckt auf das mal Twitch.
Oh, Mario, exquisite Mario Kart, Siegerehrungsmusik.
Wo habe ich meinen Prozess-Explorer da? Gucken, was da im Hintergrund gerade immer noch CPU-Leistung zieht.
Was zieht hier so viel CPU-Leistung?
Nichts. OBS. 9% CPU-Last.
Warum glaubst du, wann kann man Windows 10 im Container laufen lassen?
Gar nicht, weil gerade diese Docker-Container und Windows sind ja auch VMs.
Die haben sowas einfach nicht. Vielleicht bauen die mal irgendwann sowas. Kein Schimmer.
Aber man lässt ja auch keine Betriebssysteme in einem Container laufen. Man lässt ja eigentlich Programme plus Abhängigkeiten in einem Container laufen.
Zumindest mit Docker. Bei LXD sieht das ein bisschen anders aus.
Docker-OSX gibt es. Docker-OSX ist aber doch nur eine KVM-VM, oder?
Docker-OSX ist eine KVM-VM, die... Ach nee. Du meinst Docker auf OSX.
Ach nee. Du meinst Docker auf OSX. Wie machen die das? Ich meine, die haben ja da kein LXD laufen.
Wie machen die das unter der Haube? Ist das auch eine VM?
Wie funktioniert das unter Mac? Ah, das ist eine KVM.
Okay, ja, das ergibt Sinn. Im Prinzip das Gleiche, was Windows auch macht. Mit Windows-Docker-Containern.
Also die eigentliche Containerisierungsgeschichte, die richtig was bringt, ist dementsprechend die unter Linux.
Also wo man auch davon was hat. Nämlich, dass es deutlich weniger RAM braucht als VMs.
Also das, was man bei Containern spart, ist ja hauptsächlich Speicherplatz, nicht so sehr CPU-Performance.
Also klar, CPU-Performance ist theoretisch auch besser, aber die ist in der VM auch schon nicht schlecht.
Was man bei Containern wirklich spart, ist halt, wenn man rein aus Performance sieht, ist man spart halt viel RAM und Platz an sich.
War die anderen Vorteile außen vor gelassen.
Hast du mal was mit Selenium gemacht? Nee, aber mit Puppetier. Das ist ja auch so ein Browser-Fernsteuerungs-Ding.
So sieht's aus. Einfach mehr downloaden.
Chat, heute waren wir produktiv oder? 2 Stunden, 42 und haben alles hingekriegt, was ich so vorhatte.
Was sagst du zum Internetangebot von Easy.de? Ist das eine Pornseite oder kann ich die aufmachen im Stream ohne, dass ich geblockt werde?
Okay, das ist ein Internet-Anbieter, stimmt.
So, super, super Internet. 40 MBit. What? Was soll das sein? Ist das Mobile?
Das ist Mobile-Zeugs, oder? Die Webseite ist richtig Paynes-Champ-ig.
Ah nee, DSL. Am Hauptbahnhof, Kegwayt. An dieser Adresse nicht verfügbar. Okay, wie sieht's auf der Zeil aus?
Mainzer Landstraße? Ja, gibt's nicht.
Nö, weiß nicht. Letztendlich, wenn es DSL ist, werden die das eh nur resaleen, oder? Die haben noch bestimmt nichts Eigenes.
Gibt's eigentlich Muscle Davis noch bei 1&1? Gibt's denn noch? Wie? 957? Das ist nicht der echte.
Was ist das für eine komische Seite?
Wann hat Marcel Davis Geburtstag? Wurde am 30.07.1600 in einem Dorf im damaligen Ostpreußen geboren? Alles klar. Was ist das für eine komische Seite?
Irgend ein T-Bait-Wikipedia, oder was? Was es nicht alles im Internet gibt. Ach guck mal, MaxEye. Echt, du hast... Moment, das hab ich nicht gesehen, dass du geantwortet hast.
Ach doch, jetzt. Ja klar, ne, wir können im Discord drüber reden. Ich hab nämlich gerade die letzten Tage wieder, also ich weiß nicht, machst du noch Grafikstellzeug?
Ja anscheinend. Machst du noch so Grafikstellzeug? Weil ich hab gerade die letzten zwei Tage wieder jemand gesucht, der Thumbnails machen kann.
Für ein Special-Video. Und ich hab jetzt auch jemand gefunden, der hat das auch ganz gut gemacht, aber deine war mir schon lieber.
Ja, Twitter ist ein bisschen kaputt aktuell. RIP. Also das heißt, du kannst noch. Wenn du es noch kannst, das wäre schön, falls wir dann wieder irgendwas auf die Reihe kriegen würden.
Wie gesagt, keiner muss für mich umsonst irgendwelche Thumbnails machen. Das ist Rickroll, wenn ich da drauf klicke.
I have become my own Arch-Enemy. Anzeige ist raus.
Tja, so sieht es aus. Microsoft hat es halt überall eingekauft. Du hast quasi immer Zeit. Exzellent.
Ja gerade auch in Corona-Zeiten, ne? Ja, lass mal labern im Discord. Massive. Big. Huge. Brain. Thumbnails gibt's dann nix wieder.
Was sagst du zum Internet-Angebot von Is... Da war ich doch grad. Fuck, sah nicht so aus, als will ich mir das kaufen und dort wo ich gucken wollte, was es gibt, gab's nix.
Also woher soll ich das wissen, wenn es an den Adressen wo ich such nichts gibt? Ja, mach ich.
Du kannst einfach... Bist du bei mir auf dem Discord drauf? Oder haben wir uns im Discord geadded? Dann seh ich, wenn du online bist.
Wenn ich adde... Wenn ich adde ich dich. Schreib mal, schreib mal Discord. Wobei ich hab dich doch da drin, oder?
Wenn ich schreib mal deine Discord Hashtag-Dings im Twitter, add ich dich nachher gleich.
Leute, interessiert noch jemand, was ich zum Internet-Angebot von Easy.de sag?
Ich weiß, der Chat ist ganz scharf drauf.
Hab ich euch heute schon mal mein Heizungs-Dashboard gezeigt?
Wie sieht's aus? Heizungs-Dashboard hab ich... Ich glaub, das hab ich euch noch gar noch nie gezeigt, oder?
Mein Heizungs-Dashboard, wo ich sehen kann, Temperatur von der Heizung, Kessel-Temperatur, Brenner-Aktivität, Pumpen-Aktivität, Abgas-Temperatur und Fehler-Status.
Ich glaub, das ist zum ersten Mal jetzt reveal, das hab ich noch nie gezeigt.
Was nutzt du für deine Heizung? Für was?
Poggies liegt.
Steht der explodiert bei einem Fehler? Nee, da steht dann so was wie Fehler C1 oder so was, halt der jeweilige Fehler-Account.
Bringt einem nicht so viel, aber man kann nachgucken.
Alles klar, Max, mach ich, sobald ich hier fertig mit Stream bin.
Bin ja eigentlich mehr oder weniger durch, haben ja alles gemacht, was wir machen wollten.
Ziehst du das direkt von der Heizung, das ziehe ich über, ja direkt von der Heizung, über ein Optolink-Kabel, zieh ich das ab direkt von der Wiesmann-Schnittstelle.
Mit einem Raspberry Pi Zero, wo ein Programm von GitHub drauf läuft, was Wiesmann-Geräte auslesen kann.
Hab ich noch, ja.
Das funktioniert wunderbar.
Das geflashte Thermometer hängt bei mir am Bad in der Wand.
An der Wand, nicht in der Wand, wir sind ja hier nicht im Kokona-Haus, wo man sowas einfach in die Wand machen kann.
Und das funktioniert wunderbar, ja.
Da muss man grad mal was gucken.
Ich muss grad mal bei den, bei den chinesischen, China-Chinesen was nachgucken.
Auf AliExpress, was die Thermometer da gerade kosten, vielleicht bestelle ich mir nämlich noch zwei Stück.
Erst mal VM starten, man könnte auch so wie jeder normale Mensch auf AliExpress, aber erst mal VM starten.
Ok, heute mal Linux-basierter Hintergrund.
So, AliExpress.
Wie heißt das GitHub für Wiesmann?
Das da.
Du brauchst da aber das passende, du brauchst da aber das passende Kabel für.
Du brauchst da einen Wiesmann Optolink-Kabel für.
Da musst du mal gucken, wo es das gibt, ansonsten kann man es auch selbst bauen.
Und komm nicht auf die Idee, das offizielle, also das hier ist ein Witz.
Wie viel niemand gibt für so ein publisches Kabel, was aus einem USB-Stecker, einem Kabel und zwei Infrarot-LEDs besteht.
74 Euro aus, das ist total hängen geblieben.
Das gibt es auch deutlich günstiger, da musst du mal gucken.
Wenn nicht, kann man es auch selbst bauen.
Aber das hier brauchst du als Software.
Was wird hier gemerged? Zeig her.
Merge Republic, was die hat da.
Weiß man jetzt auch voll Bescheid.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt mal den exzellenten Source-Code an.
Ah, yes.
So schlimm ist das gar nicht.
Das kann man tatsächlich lesen.
Das ist halt C-Gefriggele, aber was willst du sonst machen?
Also genau, jetzt geht es fort.
Xiaomi Thermometer.
Kosten die hier?
Ok, ok, das lohnt sich schon mal.
Bei Amazon kostet eins, glaube ich, 12 Euro, was sich überhaupt nicht lohnt.
16 Euro für vier Stück.
Das geht doch in Ordnung.
AliExpress Standard Shipping.
11. Mai.
Oder DHL, 53 Euro.
Ja, das wirkt fast wie die Versandart, die ich da wählen würde.
So.
Xiaomi, ja?
Mit oder ohne Zollabhandlung?
Wenn du...
Gummaps gibt es sogar kostenlos.
Also irgswahrscheinlich ohne.
Die chinesischen China-Chinesen sind da sehr erfinderisch, was Zollsachen angeht.
Wie sieht es bei Banggood aus?
Thermometer, weil man Banggood kann man einstellen.
Banggood immer noch der besten Seitennamen aller Zeiten.
Was?
Hä?
Das hatten wir doch das letzte Mal, oder?
Bin ich jetzt total verwirrt?
Schiff aus Germany.
Wie, das Schiff aus Germany, da habe ich so meine Zweifel, dass es aus Germany ist.
Schiff überhaupt nicht aus Germany.
Jebaitet mich nicht.
Chinesen.
Aus Spanien Schiff, Schiff aus Spanien.
Das Schiff überhaupt nicht aus Spanien, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Zehn Tage Lieferung.
Äh...
Also...
Chinesen, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber der 11. Mai sind keine zehn Tage.
Ich kann mir da nicht helfen, aber irgendwie stimmt das nicht.
Okay, AliExpress zeigt doch wieder irgendein wirres Zeug an.
Schiff aus Spanien.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das Schiff überhaupt nicht, das Schiff aus China.
Und warum findet ihr das bei Banggood übrigens nicht?
Wie heißt denn dieses Ding?
Muss ich danach suchen vielleicht?
Findet man da jetzt was?
Nö.
Okay, dann weiß ich es auch nicht.
Wir haben das doch das letzte Mal da gefunden.
Hä?
Eben habe ich doch danach gesucht, da hat es nicht gefunden.
Die China Seiten wieder.
Die China Seiten.
Schiff aus den USA.
Schiff aus Spanien.
Schiff aus Tschechien.
Nope.
Schiff aus dem United Kingdom.
Schiff aus Russland, ja das gibt es.
Nope.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Na gut, ist auch egal.
Ich habe ja eins und das funktioniert gut, hat sich flashen lassen.
Exzellent.
So Leute, ich hoffe euch hat der Stream gefallen.
Nice, dass so viele mit am Start waren.
Wen hosten wir denn jetzt?
Ist da Frazier da?
Ups.
Alter, ich kann es ja auch machen.
Ist da Frazier am Start?
What?
Ah, nee.
Wen können wir denn hosten?
Irgendjemand da, der es wirklich gebrauchen kann, von denen, den ich follow.
Alterstein, der hat das ja absolut nicht nötig.
Ich hoste lieber Leute, die das auch wirklich was bringt.
Aber welche, denen ich selbst followe.
Poolstreamer.
Ah ja.
Genau.
Wir hosten einen Poolstream Grill.
Ok, deutsches Poolstream Grill, wen hosten wir?
Gibt es deutsche Poolstreams?
Da müssen wir jetzt gucken.
Also.
Exzellent.
Toll schon immer, Mann.
Ist Semper Video am Start?
Nope.
Was?
Kajayana streamt jetzt auch, was nicht alles gibt.
Ok, also ich gehe jetzt mal browse.
IRL.
Just chatting.
Dann, ähm, German.
Buba.TV.
Ernsthaft, das gibt's?
Haha, die Seite, fuck, das gibt's echt.
Buba.TV, ich glaub's net.
Ich glaub, aber das kann man nicht nach Deutsch filtern.
Buba.TV.
Oh Mann.
Ok, jetzt haben wir hier auf German stehen.
Deutsche Poolstream Grills.
Alles keine Poolstreams hier.
Sag bloß, das gibt's in Deutschland net.
Wir sind einfach in Deutschland nicht fähig, Trends mitzumachen.
Was Livestreaming und YouTube irgendwie angeht.
Alle auf der ganzen Welt Poolstreams am Start, in den USA, in Russland, in Korea, aber bei uns keine.
Ok, das geht vielleicht ein bisschen in die Richtung hier, aber da ist kein Wasser und sonst wie was.
Das kann ja net sein.
Außerdem ist die noch komplett angezogen, das ist auch net möglich.
Poolstreams gibt's net hier.
Keine Poolstreams.
Unglaublich.
Leute, dann hausten wir ja keinen.
Also, ich geh auf.
Bis morgen oder so.
Mal gucken.
Macht's gut.
See you.